if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dump dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps dumps dumps
dumps dump big massive dumpsters dumps
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps
[Music]
dumps dump big massive dumpsters dumps
dumps
dumps
look at that
that might come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake collars jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers this is
[Music]
ten
[Music]
elements of times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of
ten
bathrooms
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms well good morning
everybody we have a very special day
today uh in theory we are going to see
oh god what's going on with my screen
behind me
oh man hold on let me play one more
intro while i fix that that's that's
completely inappropriate i apologize
mangoes my bags are mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes
that's it all right sorry to interrupt
one of the classics but uh okay we got
the screen fixed up
in theory in about 10 uh 20 minutes we
are going to see
radical
repulsive
retrograde
rancid and raunchy
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
under oath testify
fighting for her political life
to try to stay on the re-election ballot
in georgia in november
will she show up we don't know for sure
will she
plead the fifth
we don't know we we really don't know
what to expect our friends over at midas
touch have gladly said they came to me
with tears in their eyes and they said
david sir sir sure you can use our
stream
um so thanks to the midas touch guys for
allowing us to carry their their stream
we have a backup stream
right side broadcasting we'll also be
covering this hilariously with the topic
voting rights under attack in georgia
guys the attack on voting rights was
trying to steal the election you didn't
win that's the attack on voting rights
these morons but anyway we have a backup
stream from right side broadcasting and
then we have a backup backup stream
apparently c-span will also be covering
this so
from the standpoint of streams i think
we're pretty well covered now what's at
issue here what is going on today let's
explain
january 6th to take center stage at
disqualification hearing for marjorie
taylor green
a potentially precedent setting
disqualification hearing will kick off
friday in an atlanta courtroom to
determine if republican representative
marjorie taylor green of georgia is
constitutionally barred we could also
call it being banned
from running for reelection because of
her role in the insurrection she is
expected to be called as a witness
during the marathon hearing making her
the first lawmaker to testify under oath
about their involvement in the
insurrection this all relates to a civil
war-era provision of the 14th amendment
which says any american official who
takes an oath to uphold the constitution
is disqualified from holding future
office if they quote
this is the key element
if they engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the same or given aid
or comfort to the enemies thereof how it
applies to today is a hotly debated
legal question
this is a massive legal question now
is marjorie taylor green disgusting of
course is marjorie taylor greene
a retrograde
throwback to horrible times past of
course
should marjorie taylor green not serve
another day in office for the rest of
her life of course but
is this a legal precedent that can be
used to enforce that there is a real
legal question here and i can't tell you
today that the answer is yes
okay uh the burden of proof will be on
the challengers to show by a more likely
than not standard that's an important
thing more likely than not that's like a
you know preponderance of evidence
that january 6 was legally an
insurrection
that green helped
so these are pretty significant
hurdles to overcome i i let let's not go
in with some kind of false notion that
it's going to be an easy case to prove
but this is absolutely fascinating now i
it is conceivable that marjorie taylor
green will use the gazpacho defense it
is conceivable that marjorie taylor
greene will bring in bisques or chowders
and spray them at the prosecuting
attorneys it's conceivable that she will
bring in a consummate or make this about
the difference between broth and stock
but we don't know
we just don't know
at this point in time that remains to be
seen
um the audience is absolutely shot out
of a cannon today so let's hear from
some of you um i i am so excited to see
everybody here and we are just moments
away from the start of this we have our
first super chat kevin with twenty
dollars who says is it possible that if
she's found guilty and removed from the
ballot for committing sedition it would
be used to lay the groundwork for a
criminal indictment no kevin i love you
i love the super chat but we've got a
bunch of mig so this isn't about guilt
or innocence and this isn't about
sedition
and it's not about criminal so
the answer is kevin we love the 20 super
chat but no no and no
um questions about how long the hearing
today will go i have no idea
questions about what the snacks or lunch
food will be we don't know by the way
how are the calzones pizza is here but
we have subway tomorrow yeah we just
don't know anything about that at this
point in time
um we have
huge dumps of twitch prime subscriptions
coming in i want to say a huge thank you
to wow look at all these people dranoa
guitar goddess that crazy guy grim
reaper brain matter jr dubs super
awesome stream kicking us off with seven
twitch prime subscriptions really
appreciate that guys next super chat is
from hayley
haley says will marjorie taylor br green
bring in her hippo she may claim that it
violates hipaa to be asked whether she
insurrected
um
[Music]
yeah she uh reportedly she's also going
to uh
ask for dismissal on the grounds of
giraffe
capybara and frog
which frog has never been uh invoked
in such proceedings so that actually may
throw the judge for a loop uh for lack
of a better term
um
okay a couple of yeah i do have a couple
of things i want to go through with you
guys this is just an unbelievable video
this rumor started yesterday morning
that trumpian
republican house minority leader kevin
mccarthy
was going to ask trump to resign after
the insurrection and he put out a
statement denying it up and down saying
no no no these are lies it's all untrue
and then rachel maddow got the audio
recording of him saying exactly exactly
that check this out this is this is
unbelievable
yeah
um
man the audio is terrible on this i
apologize let me see if i can find a
better one
mccarthy chaney audio that that's i
that's my fault i should not subject you
guys to crap the new york times earlier
today spokesman
let's go to the tape
here
liv you on the phone
yeah i'm here thanks kevin um
i guess there's a question when when we
were talking about the 25th amendment
resolution um
and you asked if you know what happens
if it gets there after he's gone is is
there any chance are you hearing that he
might
resign is there any reason to think that
might
happen
[Applause]
i've had some few discussions
my gut tells me no
um
i'm seriously
thinking about having that conversation
with him tonight mccarthy's saying he's
going to talk to trump tonight about
resigning he denied that this ever
happened
here he is on audio doing it talk to him
a couple days
from what i know of him i mean you guys
all know him too do you think he'd ever
back away but no what what i think i'm
going to do is i'm going to call him
my
this is what i think
nobody will pass the house
i think there's a chance you'll pass the
sanity so they're talking about
impeachment here i think i don't think
they're talking i think they're talking
about like if he was impeached
even the senate might convict
and
i think there's a lot of different
ramifications for that now i haven't had
a discussion
with them that if they did design with
it not happen mccarthy is saying here
if we told the democrats trump will
resign will they not will they will they
agree not to impeach it's insane that
this conversation happened it's
completely outrageous that this took
place i mean it's correct by the way now
this is one personal fear i have
um
i do not want some people are saying
that they're talking about the 25th
amendment the thing about the the reason
i don't think this is about the 25th
amendment is
that's the cabinet but it your you guys
are right that it's not totally clear
but the what's clear is that he was
going to talk to him about resignation
in any conversation
about
partying now see why you can't pardon
someone from a 25th amendment removal
that's why i think they're talking about
impeachment because when he says pence
pardoning to me that
the
suggests
impeachment
i would have with him
is that i think this will pass and it
will be my recommendation we should be
done it would be my recommendation you
should resign
yesterday morning kevin mccarthy denied
that this ever happened we now have
audio
just dead to rights unbelievable
all right all sorts of things are
happening thanks to techstrickle and
junk saint for gifting subscriptions
over on twitch i also want to say a huge
thank you kevin gouldy just did a
beautiful thing kevin went to my website
joinedpacman.com
signed up but instead of taking a
membership for himself kevin checked the
box this is a gift we have a list of
nearly sec 650 yes sex we have a list of
sex we have a list of nearly 650 people
that want a free membership and i'll
give them out as they are gifted the
first one goes to sean gallagher sean
thanks to kevin
you get a free membership and that's a
beautiful beautiful thing
super chats are coming in
jackson ross best junior asks if she
pleads the fifth will she still be
instructed to answer can she plead the
fifth i don't know the answer to that
we're going to find out soon we're going
to find out soon
louis cazamo says dear david i value
your content listen to your show when
i'm at work i appreciate a sa sane
centrist like you putting your voice out
there that's funny i don't know if
that's a joke
i am no centrist but it is funny that
that's uh that that's what you think by
the way yesterday i also was slammed in
20 voicemails for being a leftist
communist lunatic i'm also not that i'm
just a social democrat guys i'm like
your typical northern european social
democrat well to the left of most of the
democratic party but i guess we would
say to the right of bonafide socialists
thanks to jay putnam for the twitch
prime subscription as well you're number
11 today
let's listen to a couple of voicemails
and see if anybody has thoughts on
what's going on here good morning david
uh the popcorn is ready we are in for a
show
for the special occasion can we get an
uncharged pickles sound bite sure
uncharged piccolo's there we go
hey david this is the dog i missed you
dog uh i wanted to ask you a question
dog uh
if you had a choice between marjorie
taylor greene being the next president
dog or lauren baubert being the next
president who would you pick and why
thank you my instinct if if the next
president has to be marjorie green
taylor or lauren bo bear
i probably go with bo bear because she's
i think more of an idiot and would get
less done
it's sort of like if you give me the
choice between prompt and desantis i go
prompt because desantis is just as nuts
but less incompetent and would probably
get more done
that's my opinion it's a sick choice
it's a sick choice but that's probably
the way i would go lost in this garden
of life says via super chat david sir
how far into the hearing will marjorie
taylor green be blaming trans people for
everything i that wouldn't be a surprise
that wouldn't be a surprise i mean
listen
bill o'reilly is blaming biden for the
fact that o'reilly threatened a jet blue
worker's job at the airport
so certainly it's on the table that
green would blame trans people
or maybe even disney
maybe disney
um
let's see
[Music]
what else we've got here
hey good morning
i'm the person that calls and says
stop selling yourself
and today
i turn on the tv and i see you running
in and jumping on your bed which oh this
is a caller who just doesn't like our
ads okay well i'm sorry we have a show
to run
um next super chat trump said chakaseki
who is our radiologist in chief we
actually have a house radiologist
chakuseki for people who don't know is
actually a radiologist he's a medical
doctor
and i imagine chakuseki sitting in a
dark basement like all radiologists
they're extremely anti-social if you're
so here's basically
there's this joke that
psychiatry is the specialty for jewish
doctors who don't like blood my dad's a
psychiatrist okay that's that's what
psychiatry is radiology is the specialty
for anti-social doctors who want to not
have to speak to anybody so i imagine
chakuseki in a basement doing reports
from cat scans and then sending us super
chats that's my vision of what chakaseki
does chiaku sagi says trump said he
would ban men
and we will ban men is he doing this
through his acolyte tucker by
encouraging bros to fry their granny
smiths with tanning are zooks next yeah
tucker had a fitness expert on his show
and suggested tanning people's apple
bags the next thing would be to uh tan
the zucchini itself it's it's pretty
wild
ak green says when the insurrection
movie comes out in 2026 who would you
like to see play marjorie taylor green
my vote is for mickey rourke that's
pretty good yeah uh that's actually
that's actually pretty good let's let's
see um
mickey rourke
yeah actually this looks a lot like
margery taylor green that would be per i
can't think of a better actor to play
marjorie taylor green that's pretty
pretty damn accurate geez
spot on
straight out of central casting for sure
well i i couldn't i would say maybe lady
gaga in in makeup to make her look
rancid would be possibly but mickey
rourke isn't a bad idea
it's it's quite a resemblance yeah i
want to say thank you to ryan boyd and
fergal cosgrave who have just gifted
subscriptions on my website thanks to
them
c cook gets a membership and betsy cook
gets a membership beautiful love giving
out memberships every single day
um
do i have it yeah let's see how much
i've we've got a few minutes left let me
see if i can get a couple other things
up here for you guys rudy giuliani was
asked about his appearance on the masked
singer and he says ken jong who walked
off the set is suffering from trump
derangement syndrome
sometimes you got to do things like that
like when i used to go on saturday night
live and
let him in
anger management
i like doing comedy
the funniest thing is
the funniest things rudy has done were
not comedy
like for example is there any better
performance than when rudy had the hair
dye leaking all over him that wasn't
comedy he's a good straight man his
funniest stuff is when he does serious
stuff so what happened to that judge man
he's a little uh he's suffering from
late-stage trump derangement syndrome
right for which they have not developed
a vaccine
right
very very clever guy
and then trump also gave a speech
tonight
last night rather and said a lot of
crazy things
easy getting that from mexico
everyone laughed when i said no we're
gonna stop going in mexico they said sir
you got to be kidding we've been trying
that for 40 years are you kidding sir
they actually with a were they thinking
about uh an article 25 when i said that
right they don't think about it now by
the way it's the 25th amendment it's not
article 25 like this is like a two
corinthians moment two corinthians
walked into a bar article 25.
the 25th amendment
they don't think about that now at all
right they never mentioned the 25th but
they would mention anytime i had a great
idea 25th amendment there's something
wrong with it that's why i took the
aptitude test and i aced it according
that wasn't by the way you guys know it
wasn't an aptitude test right it was
it's just a screen it's a very
general screening for quite advanced
dementia not exactly it's not exactly
the lsat guys to doc ronnie and a whole
group of doctors i aced that aptitude
test
and that's a test that
even some geniuses in this room will not
do that well on i will tell you it's not
it's like bragging about you know uh
oh it's like hey look guys i wrote my
name down and i got a sticker for it
that easy a test
they show the first one or two questions
they're pretty easy sean you know the
first ones when you get up to questions
is he saying sean like sean hannity is
that is that hannity in the audience
that he's talking about what a bizarre
speech
that i did that they said well that all
went away i really did that i said doc
ronnie i got to take a test he said oh
wait things are starting things are
starting
[Applause]
people are clapping already oh there's
taylor green look at her
what a lunatic
what a privilege to be here with you
guys today truly what a privilege
this is insane
and yet guys yes please
join pacquiao i will thank every new
member
i appreciate the support for the early
morning stream joinedpakman.com is the
place to sign up yeah do everybody relax
i can't hear a thing
or vibration i'm going to look for a
better stream for us
thank you
thank you please be seated good morning
everybody good morning
everybody let's check this one
good morning i'm judge chuck boudreau
with the house of state administrative
hearings
senator green what the hell does that
mean senator greene
um
this is a [ __ ] show already okay is this
the mind this is my so i need to talk to
this myself
they're plagued by tech issues
do i have to use my loud voice
let's see if they're fixing it here
still not
oh this stream's a disaster this one's
better right guys is this better you
hear me okay
all right we don't only have this many
people in this courtroom
okay let's see here
some obvious things that they bear
repeating this she's not a senator guys
i don't know why it says that she's a
senator on the screen it's crazy you
might respect the
proceeding
it's
this is our big courtroom but it's quite
full so
please be you know quiet and uh again
you know you have you have phones and
computers and the like
just be very careful with them please
turn off your your any alarms
senator green this is not this is not
federal court where i would of course
you wouldn't have it in federal court i
would like to hope that you did
um
computers and finance noise to minimum
uh moving around to minimum just just
don't be disrupted no comments this is
not this is not a public forum no
comments
uh let's talk about the schedule for the
day so everybody will be sort of
prepared i plan to go until 10 45 the
first break we'll take 15 minutes then
we plan to go until uh from 11 to 12 30
with a 30-minute lunch break
we'll begin we presume at one o'clock
and
a structured break at 2 30. what a day
recommended 245
obviously if something needs to be done
or accounts need the opportunity for
whatever reason just let me know and we
will we will consider that
um
yesterday in this case
this case has been proceeding in a very
rapid rate it has to
let its election case and we had a
conference on uh evidentiary matters
and we i have reached a number of uh
preliminary conclusions about documents
that have been proper and i'm gonna it's
gonna be rather tedious but i need to
read these into the record and so and
then i want to take different counsel if
you have interesting questions you want
to
discuss in particular
um
and i'm only going to read the documents
which i have
i'm admitting
uh at this point
yes sorry i had a preliminary uh
matter uh i'd like to invoke separation
with witnesses
oh do we uh
we only have who do we have there's
there's representative professor i think
what's he invoking
us here
thank you thank you certainly
okay
all right here's what's in if at any
point anyone has a better quality stream
we can pick up let me know jesus
the video
p21
uh
the video
only
p2 n is in nancy
the uh video
p6
the video
p10 from the congressional record is in
p11
is in
p12 which is the video
p13a
is in
p14
the video only
of p16
what about this one guys
p27
p29
is this better
we can't see a thing but 36.
p41
p44 we've got some some hum
p48 249
851 p52 and 53. we've also got this one
i think it does the same thing
p 51 p 52 p53
maybe we'll stick here
pe 61
on on p62 we had a discussion about this
yesterday there's a reference to the
senate report the senate report
the thing about c-span is i don't know
where there's a stream because they're
not on they don't seem to be on youtube
p62 itself
p63 p64 p65
p66 e68 69
p72 p73
p74 and p75 p76
p80 and pc2 itself is not coming now
no response
okay here's c-span
these are like horrible horrible
feeds 76
p80 and p81 okay this isn't bad
and then on the respondents list
let's go with this this is good i'll get
it cleaned up for it
on response list
your following are admitted r1 r2 r3
r4 r5
r6
this good
and r
14. this seems like the best
will if if council want to perfect
objections at this point or raising for
the record uh i'll start with mr kelly
do you all have any objections that you
want to raise this time
your honor i don't have my list handy
but are these
preliminary rulings that you gave
yesterday yeah i mean i i believe i mean
i believe the only issue here is this
may be the only camera so let's wait and
see
today
one second you're honest sure
uh
okay i'll try to speak to it more
directly thank you thank you
go ahead uh sorry your honor i i thought
yesterday you admitted p15 as well i
didn't hear that on the list let me look
hold on
now guys the thing is if i use this
audio but a different video feed then
it'll all be out of sync that's not good
either
find it i mean i i delete one word
that
product it i mean i i if i can review it
if you was my
i'll be happy to look at it okay
that was the only i got that wouldn't be
good
i couldn't find it
and then p 55 0 i thought your honor
admitted as well let's see
p 55
the 5 0 i think i have bingo
well i thought so too i'm sorry yes that
was my other side yes
um
and then we had submitted to your honor
three additional exhibits p 82 83 and 84
yesterday afternoon oh i'm sorry yes
but wait wait let me see hold on
oh yes let me look at these uh
yes i'm sorry yes those are those are
what was 80 81 and 80
80. what a room huh
82 83 and 84.
what was 82
82 is a a video um
the house impeachment video yes yes and
yeah the house impeachment video is
interesting yes
83 was uh the january 6 letter from vice
president yes oh man
just from some of these exhibits you can
tell this is going to get very
compelling
there's your video oh of representative
greg yes yes yes that one
and then just one more yawn i i i think
on the respondents exhibits i i thought
you had admitted r7 which was a statute
i did
i hope people understand if they are
able to disqualify green from running
for her participation in inciting the
insurrection it would be an historic
moment
you're good this is green right here
on guys i i i now the lawyers in this in
this case
they're doing an excellent job and
they're under great pressure so i
appreciate everybody
staying on task
with that said
i just had
you know there's a black hole sometimes
it can be serious
okay
we're ready to begin then
as we discussed as we've discussed we're
going to proceed i'm going to i'd like
to begin with opening statements uh well
before we begin anything uh
mr pop anything that you want to discuss
before we start with the opening
statement no you're prepared for our
right oh my god her lawyer's name is mr
bob
so what we're going to do is we'll start
with opening statements i like to have
both of them at the same time the burden
in this case is on the petition type
preponderance of the evidence so they
will get to go first
we will
and then we'll proceed with uh their
case in chief
mr uh who's gonna present
thank you your honor and please the
court yes sir ron fine on behalf of the
voters in georgia's 14th congressional
district who filed this challenge
with me of course are andrew sam shapiro
diamond wells
brian sells and of course our co council
this is the best
your honor this is a solemn occasion
this is not politics this is not fear
this is a serious case
that the voters
we represent have brought
in order to offer proof that their
united states representative seeking
re-election marjorie taylor-green having
taken the oath to support the
constitution then broke that oath and
engaged in insurrection beautiful
and in order to understand that case
it's important to set the stage with
some history guys i don't i think i'm
breaking a law by how much i'm enjoying
this they might sue me
the most important of which was the
civil war or as it was called at the
time
the incorrection
and professor gerard magliaca who is one
of the nation's foremost constitutional
historians of that era specializing in
reconstruction in the 14th amendment
we'll talk about some of that history
what was interesting about some of the
differences between these past
insurrections is that the civil war
involved states raising armies they
equipped them with uniforms insignia
state-of-the-art military equipment they
marched in columns they occupied huge
tracts of land
that is not the only type of
insurrection that this country has seen
professor magliacca will also talk about
some of the previous insurrections that
were on the minds of 19th century
americans those include shae's rebellion
also known as shea's insurrection and
the whiskey rebellion
these insurrections were of a different
character they were not quite as
organized as the civil war
the
foot soldiers of those insurrections
didn't march in armies they didn't
conquer vast swaths of territory and
they certainly didn't wear uniforms
that is the kind of insurrection that
occurred on january 6th
the evidence will show a violent assault
on the united states capital
that the law enforcement and ordinary
authorities were unable to control
that this violent assault had multiple
purposes those included
capturing and executing the speaker of
the house of the united states
representatives
the vice president of the united states
and other members of congress
those purposes also included and for a
time
achieved preventing
the certification of the electoral votes
for the president incoming joseph r
biden
and
the disruption of the peaceful transfer
of power
this attack on the sacred temple of our
democracy the united states capital was
unprecedented
and to be sure it was less organized
than some of those past interactions
this was not a case where the leaders
were on horseback leaving the charge
this was not the type of insurance some
of them look like horses though standing
in richmond virginia giving long-winded
speeches to justify the mayhem
rather the leaders of this insurrection
of whom there were a number
were among us
on facebook on twitter on corners of
social media that would make your
stomach hurt
the evidence will show
that marjorie taylor green
was one of them
beautiful
in order to understand that
january 6 has to be set in context it
didn't arise out of nowhere
even before january 6th
as december 2020 turned into
january of 2021
there were multiple
shifting tactics used by
different groups some violent extremist
groups some
non-violent groups all loosely
coordinating
all with a shared central aim of
preventing the certification
of joseph biden as president
the tactics shifted
the different leaders jockeyed for
position
some were in violent extremist groups
some were elected officials some were
influencers of various fights you'll
hear about them you'll hear about
these different
figures some of whom isolated themselves
from
from some of the action with layers of
deniability some more plausible than
others
there'll be direct evidence there'll
also be inferential evidence
and that inferential evidence includes
coded language let me explain what i
mean by that the evidence today does not
include
surveillance tapes purporting to show
that marjorie taylor green was directing
the plotting of the attack that's not
going to happen today the witness list
today does not include a turncoat
witness who's going to come and risk
their own exposure by testifying
that he or she was ordered by marjorie
taylor green to take certain actions in
secret that's not the type of evidence
that we are going to present today
rather
the way that insurrections are organized
nowadays
is less in uniforms with military
hierarchies and chains of command less
with detailed military plans of battle
and more
through social media and the mass media
that's the era that we're living in in
many cases the communications have
multiple layers and anyone who knows a
teenager is a teenager or knows anyone
in their 20s knows that hashtags and
memes and ways of communicating among
internet subcultures can mean
that words that could have one meaning a
benign or even a baffling meaning to
large portions of the american public
can carry a very
different significance
to the people swimming in that
particular subculture
so the most important witness today
after professor magliacca testifies the
most powerful witness against marjorie
tyler green's candidacy
the most powerful witness in
establishing
that she crossed the line into
engagement of insurrection
is marjorie taylor green herself you
knew that was coming and hear her
of course on the stand
what she says and what she doesn't say
you'll also hear what she said in the
past again some of that will be
uh in somewhat complicated this is the
best and even if it doesn't work the
fact that she's gonna have to sit there
for days is fantastic
and she shows us exactly what she
intended
now she was not on the capitol steps
urging the
attackers to to breach police lines and
smash through the doors on january 6th
that was not the role that she played
different figures within this larger
effort had different roles
but what became clear as december turned
into january as
lawful means of preventing the
certification of joe biden were
exhausted as
non-violent even if unlawful means were
exhausted
is that marjorie tyler green nonetheless
played an important role
and her role even after she took the
oath on january 3rd
to
uphold the constitution and defend it
against all enemies foreign and domestic
to several fold
to
bring people to dc again not by
providing trains and buses that would
transport them directly
but rather through other means to
contribute in the planning
and to signal that january 6th would be
as she said herself on january 5th
our
1776 moment right a coded phrase with
great significance dog in fact it turned
out to be
an 1861 moment
instead of violence against the foreign
empire
as we saw in 1776
she urged and encouraged and helped
facilitate violent resistance to our own
government
our democracy and our constitution
and in doing so she engaged in exactly
the type of conduct
that triggers
disqualification under section 3 of the
14th amendment which is to say she
engaged in insurrection
thank you
wow thank you
and we will ban men
you better chug bro
okay would people prefer the midas touch
stream that's this one
and your honor this is a court of law
this is not a political candidate debate
this is not a place for
political hyperbole
it is not a place for political swing
it's a court of law
and what we've just heard
there was not a word
about the law
what does the 13th does section 3 of the
third of the 14th amendment mean what
does the word insurrection mean
what does the word engage me
not a word
it was not all right looks like people
people prefer this one that's fine
that's fine let's go here engage me
not a word
there was not a word about the first
amendment
that prevents normal political speech
and a hyperbole from being used against
someone
it's not a word
they think they're in the wrong place
well i plan to talk about the law
what does this
mean
this
very serious charge
that has
very broad ramifications to the rights
of representative greene the voters in
her district and our democracy
first
the right to vote is at stake
right here right now
because they want to deny the right to
vote
to the thousands of people in the 14th
district of georgia by having green
removed from the valley no
those voters have a right to vote for
the candidate of their choosing
and they have a right to have their vote
counted
now the primary is may 24
absentee ballots have already been
printed
they will be mailed on may the 2nd
and early voting starts on may the 7th
and what is their hope is that there
will be a decision by the secretary of
state
right before the primary
where she is immediately struck from the
ballot
and those people that go into the
polling place
cannot vote for their candidate of their
choice
because by utilizing this procedure
the substantial constitutional and
federal law
violations
the the defense to this will be listen
you can't just voters may want to vote
for a 10 year old for president but
you're not allowed to and if you violate
or don't meet elements of the
constitution or the rules you can't be
on the ballot
deciding issues of that magnitude before
being subject to
a trial
before
being penalized
by disqualification
and before the irreparable harm that
will occur if that occurs
but that's the nature of the procedure
when can representative green raise her
constitutional
defenses like
the evidence you are presenting violates
the first amendment to the constitution
there it is
when are we going to be able to litigate
that question there it is in state court
after she's disqualified after she's
stripped from the ballot maybe after the
primary occurred
and she loses well sorry nobody can vote
for her and obviously loses it
well whoop-de-dean
okay how do we recover from that how do
we go back from that
these are
these are irrevocable this is
harm to the voters and to the candidate
now second
our democracy is at stake
yeah it should not be it should be the
voters
not government employees public
officials judges and lawyers who decide
our elections
voters have a right to vote for the
candidate of their choice
unless there's very compelling legal
not rhetorical
justification for that
third and which is not present here
third
fundamentally first amendment rights are
at stake
not only the right to vote as i
mentioned everybody in the chat who said
they're gonna make it a first amendment
issue you were right
will try to use
the first amendment protected political
speech of representative green as
evidence of quote
engaging in an insurrection or rebellion
that's unconstitutional and should not
be allowed
and finally
the charge not only triggers
disqualification
but is a serious federal criminal
offense
that she is being charged with beautiful
now this is a very serious matter and
the decision should be based on
admissible evidence under the rules
we are we recognize you have greater
latitude than that
uh but
the the charges the seriousness of the
charges we think weren't that adherent
and faithful application of the law
and we expect you
that you will do that
now procedure
georgia law and here i am talking about
the law
georgia per law
21-2-5 permits a candidate challenge
under two circumstances one
a candidate a candidate is not qualified
to be a candidate
all right
and number two is
a candidate is not qualified to take
office
of course these are different
different conceptually and different in
their application
so
a claim under
section 3 of the 14th amendment has to
do with
what your your ability to take office
because it not
it doesn't address candidacy in any way
it's the ability of a representative in
this case to take office
because
she has
sworn the oath of office
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
right congress has not
given her amnesty
and finally she when she presents
herself
to take the oath of office she could be
challenged
which we think is the exclusive
constitutional right of congress not
state officials to decide
whether or not she is eligible at that
time to take office
so
we're not dealing with a candidacy
disqualification we're dealing with a
alleged take office qualification
now uh
unfortunately as i've mentioned
many of these issues cannot be decided
by this court
even though you might make
recommendations of the secretary of
state on the map
and we have fully briefed this already
in our motion to dismiss and to stay the
proceedings
the
constitutional claims the federal law
claims the protections of the first
amendment speech and debate
and what these
words in section three
mean
so let's look at that
uh
we have our we
limited evidence is r2 which is the 14th
amendment and it includes of course
section three
and section three provides
that no person shall be a senator or
representative in congress
etc etc etc
having previously taken an oath as a
member of congress for an officer of the
united states executive
to support the constitution shall
have engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the same or given aid
and comfort to the enemies thereof
pretty clear so there's a sequence
you have to have originally taken the
ill
you have to then engage
and then you can't you are disqualified
and uh congress can determine that
you're disqualified for having done that
from taking a subsequent vote
and therefore cannot assume your your
position as a member of congress
and then furthermore but congress may by
a vote of two-thirds of each house
remove such disability
and of course that's the
various amnesty acts that have been
adopted or could be adopted by by
congress
now this
provision
as i mentioned makes it clear this is
about eligibility on january 3rd
2023
not today
not tomorrow
but eligibility when she presents
herself as a re-elected member of
congress
she could be
excluded under the exclusive power of
congress to judge the qualifications of
its members
that's
where these people should be
in congress
explaining why she
uh once she is reelected so so far he's
not saying she didn't incite an
insurrection he's just saying the time
to challenge that would be if she wins
and is set to be sworn back in in
january
in her case she took the office first
the further first time
and these are in our stipulated backs
right
on january the 3rd that's the first time
and so she would have had to engage in
insurrection or rebellion
after january 3rd
in other words under the
the timing of her insurrecting is not
appropriate to disqualify her now this
is known as when you can argue the facts
you argue the facts when the facts
aren't in your favor you are argue
procedure it's not unique to this case
she
she
she
reveres the united states
constitution reverie but
the way the statute or the
constitutional provision is set up
she would have to have engaged after
so
evidence of anything she did prior to
june
january 3rd is just
completely irrelevant to the section 3.
unless it is direct at a direct
admission
of her intention to engage in
insurrection what an argument after
january 3rd
anything else she says is not only it
should be excluded because it doesn't
fit
the charge right
but as i will soon demonstrate it is
protected by the first amendment
now here
words matter
and at every turn the challengers
mistake what the law is in their
complaint obviously they didn't discuss
it here
uh but in their complaint
and calling something something
doesn't make it something
a orange an apple does not make the
orange an apple
take a look at the oranges
and orange has characteristics
that
are pre-established
and are applied to determine whether the
word apple
applies
here
the key phrases in
section 3 are themselves
defined
by the law
now
they start off
in misstating the law
by saying
that
representative green should be
disqualified under section three this is
also called by the way the
disqualification club
because she is someone who quote aided
and
engaged in an insurrection and a quote
complaint
page one
aided and engaged
where is that in section three
it says
engaged in insurrection or rebellion or
gave aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof
right
there's no aided
and engaged in this
in this
in this statute
now each of those phrases
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
that phrase and the and is four
accompanying uh
praise gives aid or comfort to the enemy
zero
each of those has special meaning
engage is
an act
it is
a direct and overt act
of
insurrection
it is about as one commentator said
domestic war
that's what engaged in insurrection
rebellion counselor are you on downers
the or
giving aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof
as the same commentator said is about
foreign wars
each of these phrases have been used
several times in federal law
and have come to
a gain
particular meaning their words of art
so you can't take
aid
out of the second part
about foreign wars
and add it to the first part that is
about domestical
that defies the rules of construction it
flaunts the the
technical and
meaning of those phrases of those words
so what is engaged and what does it mean
well engage connotes conda
a direct over act of
insurrection to overthrow the united
states government
it is about things like
which the people who drafted this well
understood many of them were
uh
part of the victorious thank the lord
union army
and they they knew what an insurrection
or rebellion was
so it was taking up arms voluntarily
joining the confederate army it was
about
working in the war department
for the confederate government
it was about i'm with many people in the
audience that she's not going to be
disqualified but the fact that she's
even been put in this position is
absolutely delightful
so these were
direct overt acts of insurrection
now
instead of
looking to that
what we have already heard described as
their evidence and and of course as well
revealed in their complaint
they want us they want to hold against
her first amendment protected speech
and here's a few examples
on
page 19
quote the people will remember the
patriots who stood for election
integrity
that is supposed to be
about an insurrection or engaging in an
insurrection
or they said she said she's alleged to
have said
uh quote congress is the last line of
defense
from a stolen election end of quote on
page 21.
isn't that quintessential political
speech
isn't that recognizing the role of
congress and certifying the electors
how could that be interpreted as
in
as an overt act to engage in
insurrection or redundant
well
it can't be
and
now
the question of voter fraud in the 2020
election
it was a is a quintessential example
of political speech
legitimate political disagreements
about what happened
not really yeah you know a supreme court
in republican party in minnesota versus
white but
actually the first one i argued
in the court
said that announcing
views on disputed legal or political
issues is at the core of the first
amendment
at the core
now this is
disputed
no question
but
but to say that is an act of
insurrection it is a
direct overt act of insurrection against
the united states
when
representative green was an elected
member of congress who on january 6 had
a constitutional duty and responsibility
to be on the floor where she was
to determine whether or not
certain votes electoral votes from
trump's the states would be certified
now this the first amendment demands a
very narrow test
i've already said
and argued that engage
is connote's conduct
but we can look to a much broader term
that actually allows speech to be
considered
and that is the brandenburg case in the
naacp case which we saw
and that is the word in uh incitement
now
incitement and
engage are different words with
different meanings
and in fact you know that for sure
because there are federal statutes that
that say
inside
and then say engage in certain conduct
i mean they're used as different words
incitement the supreme court has said is
speech
but
the supreme court because of first
amendment concerns so that
normal everyday political speech
will not be punished
as they want to do
says that is that
that speech
must be
quote directed to inciting or producing
just think about this as building
character having to suffer through this
guy to get to the green testimony that's
the way i'm mentalizing it
or produce such action and quote that's
on page
30 of our motion to dismiss
that is very restrictive
right but we know how restrictive it
really is
when we
point out the statements that are made
where people are claiming that is
incitement
and the supreme court says no that's
protected by the first amendment
for instance
a ku klux klan leader clue
quote
advocated the duty necessity
and propriety of crime sabotage violence
or other unlawful methods of terrorism
as a means of accomplishing industrial
or political reform
and the supreme court said that is
protected first amendment speech that is
not sight incitement
there was also a
a statement um
by uh
an naacp official
where this definitely seems like the
type of guy who would have his stake
super well done any of them racist
stores
we're gonna break your damn neck
and the quote
that was not incitement
under the brandenburg test
and we also have seen
where a vietnam war protester
said
we are taking the
f
street again and a quote and that was
not
incitement under the brandenburg test
there is absolutely nothing
that representative green ever said
that passes the brandenburg type the
test of incitement
and
she can't even be held into account for
incitement
because
uh this is engaged
which requires conduct
look they knew what the words
meant
and and they chose the words
that they were going to use this was
going to be a very narrow
and char
disqualification
now
then they claim
that representative green judge about to
ask caffeine pills be brought in
the january 6 rally
away from the capitol
right
near the white house
and where some of the people at that
rally
went to the capitol and some of those
attacked the capital
and i call it an attack
it was despicable
for these people to do this
to attack the capital of the united
states
so over 700 have been charged with
crimes if they are guilty they should be
convicted of those crimes
but you know not a single one of them
has been charged with
engaging in insurrectional rebellion
which is a federal criminal thing
not one
another one of the people that actually
attacked the capitol assaulted police
officers broke in and were there
unlawfully
well the first amendment right to
assemble
means
that the right to assemble does not lose
all constitutional protections merely
because
some members of that group may have
participated in conduct or advocated
uh doctrine that itself is not protected
so this was a
quintessentially protected first
amendment right of assembly
and that some people left and went to
the capitol some people
attacked the capital
you can't help hold the people who who
organized the peaceful and
constitutionally protected rally
they kind of hold that that against them
because that's what they did
now
second
second
the
challengers
mistake the law regarding what is an
insurrection or rebellion
they they say
it is
quote to overthrow the government or or
obstruct its core functions period end
quote that's on page 32.
nowhere in any case
does it say
that insurrection includes
obstruct
its core
function
it certainly says overthrow the
government and you know certainly infra
you know if that would occur
you guys hear that wine would transfer
to someone else right
but
they want
to
expand this
so that for instance
when a heckler in the house gallery
stands up and heckles
the congress you know the house and they
have to suspend
that that person is guilty of
insurrection or rebellion because
a core function has been obstructed
but this word is way
more
serious the judge is in a rush because
he has the mike pillow case right after
this we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines examples of what
the either statutes or the courts etc
have said
a domestic war
that is on page 20 of our submission
motion to dismiss
a domestic war
second and that was the attorney general
in 1867
two combinations too powerful to be
suppressed by ordinary course
of judicial proceedings or by the
marshall
that was temporarily
so apparently
i don't know
but even if it were it wasn't you know
it was temporary and short-lived
third
a rising so formidable
uh-oh
we just lost the feed
let's refresh
oh they they lost it all together okay
let's switch to here and the military
wasn't required to
even uh for the temporary attack
collapsed
too strong now it must be back and the
military wasn't required they've
switched over to this
for the temporary attack
uh
an armed insurrection too strong to be
controlled by civil authorities
and then finally
the uh uh the court in allegheny
uh city
juxtaposed what the insurrection is and
what in this direction isn't it
what the hell
an insurrection is an organized and
armed uprising against authority or
operation
of government
it is not
while crimes growing out of mob violence
which we certainly had on january 6
however serious they may be
or however numerous the participants
are simply
unlawful acts in disturbance of the
peace
which do not threaten the stability of
the government or the existence of
political society
they're different dramatically different
now
we have stipulated
that
a group of people
that did not include representative
green
unlawfully entered the united states
capital on january 6th
and they did
i mean i say more about i say more than
that about what happened
as i just have before your report your
honor on behalf of representative greene
excuse me just to say yeah i apologize
mr pop uh
mr hamilton
sorry
that's our my guy who needs to help us
with the sounds
excuse me just a second i hope he helps
us with the temperature
wow i'm just gonna momentarily mute it
while they get that that that almost
reminds me of when they um
uh
you know terrorized trump's rallies with
bad
audio and aren't
credible oh these people don't know what
the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for once
okay they're about to fix that in the
meantime i want to say thanks to zoey
loffer and annabelle harwell for signing
up on my website joinpakman.com
uh we do depend on the support of folks
who sign up at joinpakman.com and i
would love it if you did that if you
have a membership you can also gift one
by checking that this is a gift box
that
if there is conduct
that meets the term engage i mean that
if there is contact that would ever meet
the term engaged
it would be
breaking into the capital that would be
an engagement certainly an over
direct overt act
and
however
i think
describing that as
insurrectional rebellion is just
political hyperbole
and not under the constitution
and that's what you have to engage in
now
what you will see
is pertinent evidence
about what you did
from from us
from january 3rd
until uh the end of the day on january
6th
and uh you know you you will see now
there's a reason that they only want to
focus on her actions in those three days
which they argue is all that matters
because their actions outside of those
three days were pretty insane
to certain states electoral votes based
upon evidence
that she believed and others believed
constituted
sufficient voter fraud to overturn the
election in those particular states
you will see
that on january 6th
and of all the tweets
and all the videos
we we are presenting this video
this is
during the moment when the attack on the
capital was occurring
and she is in the capitol
in a dark hallway
and she says
first in in the tweet accompanying the
video
which they do quote in their complaint
be safe
be smart stay peaceful obey the laws
this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump and support election integrity
which they believed they were doing on
the floor of the united states
and then the
video
i so i urge you to remain calm i urge
you to have a peaceful protest make sure
that everyone is safe and protected
and let's do this in a peaceful manner
this is this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump support elections activity and
support this important process
that we're going through in congress
where we're allowed to object
so this this is very important so i urge
you to stay calm be the great american
people that i know you are
and just know that you are that were in
the fight for you
god bless everyone be careful be safe be
smart and obey the law
a few days later after the
attack occurred she said
we it's almost making me tearful how
strongly marge supports the constitution
and voter integrity
the january 6th attack
and then
fbi director ray testifies before
a committee of congress this is r5
i was appalled like you he's addressing
members of congress
at the violence and destruction that we
saw that day
i was appalled
that you
members of congress
our
country's elected leaders were
victimized right here in the very halls
of congress
representative greene was a victim of
this attack
right her life was in danger she said
she's the victim she was scared and
confused
her children were frantic
about what was going on and fearfully
she was surprised that the thing she was
suggesting people do was happening you
planned the attack
would
react
and you will see her reaction
and you will then hear her testimony
so
the attack on the u.s capitol as
despicable as it was was not an
insurrection or rebellion and she
certainly did not engage in it as
understood under the law that is what
the evidence will prove
and why she should remain among multiple
other reasons
thank you thank you
mr mbop
all right
let's start with uh professor mclaughlin
was announced his name again i'm sorry
maybe okay
i apologize
for each other
um your honor i want to start just by
reading into the record the stipulated
facts it'll take a moment uh
if you want to read them that's fine
but you can read them the parties to the
above caption proceedings through their
undersigned counsel stipulate that the
following facts are true
that the respondent is over the age of
25
the respondent has been a united states
citizen for more than seven years the
respondent is inhabitant of georgia
petitioners are all registered voters in
georgia's 14th congressional district
on january 3
2021 the respondent took the oath of
office to be a member of the us house of
representatives for the first time
a joint session of congress was called
to order at or around 1pm on january 6
2021 for the purposes of opening
counting and resolving any objections to
the electoral college vote of the 2020
u.s presidential election and certifying
the results of the electoral college
vote
a group of people that did not include
the respondent unlawfully entered the
united states capital on january 6 20.
so they're just reading a document
that's already been submitted so i'll
catch everybody up on what's going on
this started around 9 30 a.m eastern
time the um opening statements were made
by the plaintiffs the complainants i
think they're called in what are they
called in this case the petitioners uh
and marjorie taylor green's defense
soon they are going to move into
witnesses the first break is scheduled
for 10 45 a.m eastern time that's in
about 19 minutes and that's a short
break probably only snacks maybe light
refreshments pretzels potato chips that
sort of thing and then a longer lunch
break later professor gets going here
good morning
right hand yes
you solemnly swear our affirmative
testimony of giving us hearings the
truth the whole truth enough about the
truth of god
okay
good morning secretary can you just
repeat your full name for the record
gerard magliacca and what's your
profession i am the samuel r rosen
professor at the indiana university
robert h mckinney school of law what's
your educational background
i received my college degree at stanford
and my law degree from yale whoa
summarize your professional experience
since then yes i was a law clerk for one
year
and then i was an associate at a law
firm for two years and i've been a
teacher for the past 21 years
and your honor we would say that p61 his
resume has already been admitted to
evidence correct so we don't need to
recreate it professor magneto what are
your areas of research
my main area of research is american
constitutional history and you don't
have a phd in history though do you i do
not so what is your experience working
with historical materials
well i do work at archives around the
united states on books that i write so
for example i've worked at the library
of congress mount vernon the chicago
history museum
the national archives and as well as
other facilities that hold documents and
how much of your work has been original
historical research using original
historical materials well more than half
i mean obviously i use secondary sources
read other books and articles to do my
research give me just a second i think
you know they having difficulty
oh okay sorry yes you
have unfortunately i've talked to the
students
yes
what the hell
did you need to finish that question uh
would you like me to repeat my name
yes i would say i do more than half of
my work on primary sources
and then the remainder consists of
reading the other books or articles
written about the subjects that i'm
studying please what methods do you use
when you're conducting this original
historical research well i use the same
methods that a historian would use so
for example i try to identify documents
and make sure they are authentic
i try to understand the documents based
on what was going on at the time
and also to make sure that i'm quoting
them in context rather than out of
context for example have you ever heard
the phrase law office history yes i have
what do you understand that phrase to me
it means reaching a conclusion and then
trying to find historical materials to
justify the conclusion that you've
already reached and how does your
research the same or different from law
office history well i don't have any
particular conclusion when i begin a
project i do the research with the
materials and then i gradually reach a
conclusion based on what i read and what
i see
now i'm not going to ask you to repeat
your entire bibliography but
specifically with respect to your
historical research on the 19th century
how many if if any books have you
published five and what subjects were
they about
well the first one was about andrew
jackson and the period in which he was
president the second was the period at
the end of the 19th century when william
okay to everybody asking if marjorie
taylor greene will testify she will be
testifying marjorie taylor green will be
testifying under oath john bingham who
was one of the principal framers of the
14th amendment the fourth is a book on
the bill of rights that covers
the entire history of the bill of rights
including the 19th century portion and
the one that i've just written is about
george washington's nephew
who was uh bushrod washington who was a
justice of the supreme court for 30
years in the early 19th century in
addition to these books have you
published academic articles and academic
journals about 19th century uh
constitutional history yes i published
about 10 articles
that relate to 19th century
constitutional history in various
germans we believe today
three years
have you been asked to give any academic
lectures or speeches outside your
university on 19th century
constitutional history
well of course they were virtual because
of the pandemic but but yes i just i
gave a
talk at mount vernon in 2021 about the
book the bushrad washington book um and
i've been doing some other things
related to that that's been the main
source of lecture that i've done and
have you received any fellowships or
professional recognition for this work
yes i was a fellow at mount vernon from
2019 to 2021
where i worked in the archives there on
the porch rod washington project looking
at his letters and other correspondence
that was related to my research and then
turning to the 14th amendment and
section 3 in particular have you
conducted any research on this yes i
have and can you describe in broad terms
that research yes in the fall of 2020 i
researched and wrote a paper on section
3 of the 14th amendment
the paper was completed in december and
made available to researchers and anyone
to see on the social science research
network
that happened around december 10 2020
and what perspectives do you use to
address questions about the 14th
amendment well primarily i look to what
was said in congress about the amendment
proposal
because that's sort of well most
important initial source
uh then i also look to secondary sources
outside of congress for example what did
newspapers have to say about this is a
petitioner witness guys for people
asking
that we can find out about the
ratification of the 14th amendment
so it's primarily looking to the
discussion or conversation that
americans had about the 14th amendment
when it was proposed and under
discussion for ratification and how are
these approaches similar or different
from the types of ordinary legal
analysis that lawyers and judges
ordinarily do
well i mean there's some overlap of
course but the i focus much more in my
work on the
surrounding politics or social aspects
of what's going on at these particular
times with these particular
constitutional issues rather than
focusing more on the text or the
cases uh so obviously you have to do
some of both but
i'm more of a
you know more of a historian than uh
okay the petitioners are free speech for
people doing the legal representation on
behalf of voters in marjory taylor
greene's district
i object your honor number one
he was not tender as an expert in
the specification of witnesses
number two that they have provided is no
expert report
which is required for such an expert
uh so that we can prepare for his
testimony they don't want him
uh he has not produced the to us
the documents that he relied upon in
order to reach whatever conclusions the
expert
report reveals so we under civil rules
in georgia that's all required
none of that occurred here and it is
fundamentally unfair
for us to
show up at hearing with no preparation
other than
his resume
which we got
a couple days ago and uh and
cross-examined him without an adequate
opportunity to prepare prepare that is
always provided for a expert witness
as i have said before
i was unclear what the role is for the
for
the professor
uh paul he's indicated his art is he
going to testify essentially to the
contents of his article that he wrote
you know your honor the the subject
matter of the questioning would uh
address matters that were not entirely
embraced within the context of his law
or the article
you know i i apologize i have one other
uh comment yes
and i was going back and forth whether
or not this is proper when he starts
answering asking questions or now but i
want to raise it
uh
what
he has described
is
his expertise
expertise
and what he has
been said he will testify about are
quintessential
legal questions
if a statute is vague you look to the
legislative visitor
that's what he wants to testify about
that's a legal
uh question so the defense is already
saying they don't want the first witness
to be allowed to
testify a
person to testify about these are about
facts
about what happened
on january 6
before
and not on legal matters this is
quintessential that legislative industry
is quintessentially what his lawyers do
and judges decide
though i would inject generally on that
ground
i'm struggling because
i'm trying to it you know we don't i
don't know what the testimony is going
to be i mean it's a circular question
but
the issue of the history of the 14th
amendment if
the petitioners want to spend their time
with a history of the enactment 14th
amendment i will listen
but i concur with you that i will not
permit and will not entertain testimony
regarding
the meaning of statutes or anything that
would be properly the subject of
briefing so
what i
i will let you start
but
and i would also suggest i mean to me
this all sounds like the sort of stuff
that would be coming in appropriately in
the briefing
uh and if you have articles and
authorities and original documents that
you wish to cite i'm happy to read them
but i don't know that it makes sense
for us to be dealing with a series of
objections on things which are
historical in nature
so
i will let you start
but i may stop you
okay
and i will entertain objections if the
winning has approached oh this is going
to be a nightmare
thank you
um professor can you just briefly
summarize the historical context for
section 3 of the 14th amendment
yes so after the civil war elections
were held across the south for congress
and for the senate and some of the
people who won had been leaders in the
confederacy they arrived in washington
seeking to take their seats
northern public opinion was outraged at
this because these were some of the same
people who had led secession
so
those members were excluded from
congress and then
consideration was given to some formal
proposal that would exclude them for
some period of time
afterwards and who are the primary
framers of this
i think so section three of the 14th
amendment was drafted by senator jacob
howard of michigan
and it was
narrower than the original proposal that
had been put forward in the house of
representatives so the house proposal
for section 3 would have prohibited
all former confederates from voting in
federal elections until 1870. so the
senators considered that too broad and
unfair
so the substitute drafted by senator
howard focused and set on office holding
rather than voting and did not apply to
anyone who had been engaged in
insurrection instead it applied only to
officials either current or former and
civil or military
on the thought that it was the leaders
of the insurrection who should be
held accountable rather than
ordinary followers
and in developing section 3 the 14th
amendment did the framers look to any
historical examples of this okay people
wondering about this woman here that's
not a hookah she is the court reporter
and that's a device that sort of like
keeps her voice contained so as not to
distract the witness and she is trans uh
transcribing i don't know what the right
word would be she's noting what's being
said well known to reasonably educated
mid 19th century americans well there
were two one was shae's rebellion which
was also referred to as shea's
insurrection and the other was the
whiskey rebellion which was also
referred to as whiskey the whiskey
insurrection
uh so let's let's start with shay's
insurrection or shea's rebellion um when
and where did that occur
so shades rebellion occurred in
massachusetts at the end of 1786 and
early 1787 it was a tax protest by
farmers
who were upset about
high land taxes
and that had led to many foreclosures of
farms so what started happening was that
groups of farmers would arm themselves
and go to local courts
to basically stop the courts from
operating so that foreclosure sales
could not happen
uh this built up to a point where the
state militia was called in to sort of
deal with this suspension of the normal
operation of the courts by
armed people
and that led to a clash at an armory
when some of the um sort of
insurrectionists decided to try to take
some weapons um four people were killed
and after that the
rebellion of insurrection ended
you said that their goal was to stop the
courts from operating
that is that that's correct to prevent
foreclosure sales on farms
and
from a historical perspective what were
the key features of shae's rebellion
that would be remembered in the mid 19th
century by reasonably educated americans
well that it was an effort by armed
people to suspend the civil authority of
government for a period of time and it
was considered a significant event
because it seemed to have an influence
on the framers when they gathered in
philadelphia for the constitutional
convention because they saw it as an
example of why we needed to replace the
articles of confederation with a new
constitution
was it considered an insurrection or
rebellion or both
well so in federalist number 10
james madison
uh the subtitle of federalist number 10
was the union as a safeguard against
domestic faction and insurrection
so and he was referring to shea's
insurrection as well as some other
upheavals that had happened in the
states uh prior to that uh and then in
the 19th century a well-known book by
justice joseph story referred to the
insurrection in massachusetts story was
from massachusetts so it probably
explains why he emphasized that point in
his book
uh thank you let's talk about the other
one you mentioned the whiskey rebellion
or whiskey insurrection what was that so
the whiskey insurrection was another tax
protest
by farmers this time on a federal tax on
whiskey and other spirits
um so farmers in pennsylvania were upset
about this and they decided to start
getting armed and trying to prevent tax
collection um they did this in various
ways sometimes they would
well in one case they tarred and
feathered a tax collector
totally reasonable basically attack uh
places where the tax collectors were
known to be and they also shut down
courts because again to some degree the
courts were necessary to further the
collection of the taxes because
sometimes there were foreclosures that
were required to you know pay the taxes
that were owed
uh how many casualties were there in the
whiskey rebellion there were four or
five people were killed in some
skirmishes eventually
george washington called in a large
force more than 10 000 troops to go into
that portion of pennsylvania and
basically for the most part the
insurrection just ended because of the
site of this large force led by george
washington pretty interesting four or
five people were killed how well
organized was the whiskey rebellion
well it was a loosely organized thing
um
there were mostly local groups doing
different things there wasn't really a
single leader
at all
that we know of
and by the time of the 1860s
how well known was the whiskey rebellion
to
ordinary educated 19th century americans
he's already conceded that in the debate
they were talking about the civil war
not what these were colloquially called
insurrection
not the legal definition under the
sustained sections
if i recall your earlier testimony
correctly uh you said that uh four
people died in
shae's rebellion and four or five in the
whiskey rebellion to him
going on with this i object to talk
about something that was a real relevant
as late even legislative history
regarding title three again these were
never signed overruled go ahead
overruled
should i have those numbers right you
said four four or five people died in
each of those insurrections correct
so
to the extent that 19th century
americans
thought of these as insurrections in
addition to of course the civil war uh
how would 19th century americans have
understood what level of violence or
bloodshed was needed before the word
insurrection would be used
well some violence was required because
there were there was no thought really
that you could have a peaceful protest
and that would be considered an
insurrection but there was no particular
thought about how much violence was
required
and how would they distinguish between
or would they distinguish between a riot
versus an insurrection
what sources
did
19th century americans use to understand
the meanings of words
objects there's no foundations in the
length of that question
all right
um
yeah just stay standing i'd like to
display an exhibit that's already been
admitted into evidence which is p81 p81
okay
bear with me
it is shocking that marge hasn't jumped
up and objected herself but they
probably have her on downers
that's a joke by the way look at the uh
yeah one more page
imagine if they put up the video of of
marge doing that crazy uh work like
pull-up thing where she's like her
body's like a like a wet noodle
how was that dictionary used in 1830 and
afterwards well it was the leading
dictionary in the united states during
this period
excuse me what what period we talked
about
1830 okay 18 curve okay
uh was
the dictionary updated on a semi-regular
or regular basis after that yes much
like modern dictionaries they would do a
new edition every so many years
but this is the 1830 edition yes
and
you're familiar with this dictionary
you've seen it before yes i am uh to
what extent does it inform if at all
your understanding of how words were
used in the
mid-19th century
they used racist glue in this dictionary
i object
let's turn to page
the next page
and if we could zoom in on the uh left
column
and uh
the top can you can you read that that's
our background okay the little facebook
okay can you zoom it even more back
i will
do my best
okay
can you yes i think i can can you uh
read a couple entries down and i'm not
going to ask you to read it aloud um
but do you uh see their uh
the the do you read the definitions
there yes i can uh are you familiar with
if this dictionary has a definition for
insurrection yes it does
and
what what can you without reading from
that uh that definition uh is that
in your experience as a historian is
that typical of a 19th century
understanding of the word insurrection
pain you don't even stand up document
speak for itself counselors next fair
enough
uh
how do you use these dictionaries in
your own work
well they're helpful in putting terms
into context for example if i'm reading
a letter and i'm trying to understand
what somebody meant you know sometimes
the definition that people used back
then isn't the same as the definition
that we use now so it's uh
you have to check
right let's go to exhibit p80 if we may
this has also been admitted into
evidence e80 yes
all right guys i've got to go be
interviewed for a british show the
stream will continue marjorie taylor
green's coming up feel free to hang out
i'll be back as soon as the interview's
over and we'll keep going we'll figure
out what we're having for lunch and
everything all right stand by
this is a statute a georgia statute
enacted in 1866
and why did the what is the statute
about insurrection and do you know why
georgia enacted this action
i believe it was because of the it was
in response basically to what had
occurred during the civil war
and
uh
your honor i haven't asked a question
yet
i would object to
you may ask me a question captain maybe
i should just stand
all right
i'm sorry this is very serious stuff but
what what concerns me mr fine
is
this is what i would expect to be
reading in briefs this is not what i
expected your testimony on this is
historical data
that can be reviewed and commented on
and proffered and so forth i'm indulging
you because of the importance of this
hearing but
you may ask the question i will if i
hear an objection i'll rule
go ahead thank you your honor um
when
all right
briefly confirm sure sure
in fact we're actually past my 10 45
break so let's take our break we'll
reconvene
no no no no stop that this is not a show
do not do that
we will stop now we'll reconvene at uh
yes i know just sometimes
like how close we're supposed
thank you
[Music]
um
okay
so this court hearing challenging
georgia republican representative
marjorie taylor greene's candidacy for
re-election as you heard taking a brief
break here we're expecting them back
at 11 o'clock eastern our live coverage
will continue when the hearing resumes
here live on c-span while we wait we'll
show you some of the hearing from
earlier today
ron fine on behalf of the
voters in georgia's 14th congressional
district who filed this challenge
with me of course are andrew sam shapiro
diamond wells
brian sells and of course our co-counsel
watching remotely
your honor this is a solemn occasion
this is not politics this is not theater
this is a serious case
that the voters
we represent have brought in order to
offer proof that their united states
representative seeking re-election
marjorie taylor green having taken the
oath to support the constitution then
broke that oath and engaged in
insurrection
and in order to understand that case
it's important to set the stage with
some history
there have been past insurrections in
this country and we're going to hear
about some of them the most important of
which was the civil war or as it was
called at the time
the incorrection
and professor gerard magliacca who is
one of the nation's foremost
constitutional historians
of that era specializing in
reconstruction in the 14th amendment
we'll talk about some of that history
what was interesting about some of the
differences between these past
insurrections is that the civil war
involved states raising armies
they equipped them with uniforms
insignia
state-of-the-art military equipment they
marched in columns they occupied huge
tracts of land
that is not the only type of
insurrection that this country has seen
professor magliacca will also talk about
some of the previous insurrections that
were on the minds of 19th century
americans those include shae's rebellion
also known as shay's insurrection the
whiskey rebellion these insurrections
were of a different character they were
not quite as organized as the civil war
the
foot soldiers of those insurrections
didn't march in armies they didn't
conquer vast swathes of territory and
they certainly didn't wear uniforms
that is the kind of insurrection that
occurred on january 6th
the evidence will show a violent assault
on the united states capital
that the law enforcement and ordinary
authorities were unable to control
that this violent assault had multiple
purposes those included
capturing and executing the speaker of
the house of the united states
representatives
the vice president of the united states
and other members of congress
those purposes also included
and for a time achieved
preventing
the certification of the electoral votes
for the president incoming joseph r
biden
and
the disruption of the peaceful transfer
of power
this attack on the sacred temple of our
democracy the united states capital was
unprecedented
and to be sure it was less organized
than some of those past interactions
this was not a case where the leaders
were on horseback leaving the charge
this was not the type of insurrection
where the leaders were
standing in richmond virginia giving
long-winded speeches to justify the
mayhem
rather the leaders of this insurrection
of whom there were a number
were among us
on facebook on twitter on corners of
social media that would make your
stomach hurt
the evidence will show
that marjorie taylor green
was one of
them in order to understand that
january 6 has to be set in context it
didn't arise out of nowhere
even before january 6
as december 2020 turned into
january 2021
there were multiple
shifting tactics used by
different groups some violent extremist
groups some
non-violent groups all
loosely coordinating
all with a shared central aim of
preventing the certification
of joseph biden as president
the tactics shifted
the
different leaders jockeyed for position
some were in violent extremist groups
some were elected officials some were
influencers of various types you'll hear
about them you'll hear about
uh these different uh figures some of
whom isolated themselves
from
from some of the action with layers of
deniability some more plausible than
others
there'll be direct evidence they'll also
be inferential evidence
and that inferential evidence includes
coded language let me explain what i
mean by that the evidence today does not
include
surveillance tapes purporting to show
that marjorie taylor green was directing
the plotting of the attack that's not
going to happen today the witness list
today does not include a turncoat
witness who's going to come and risk
their own exposure by testifying uh that
he or she was ordered by marjorie taylor
green to take certain actions in secret
that's not the type of evidence that we
are going to present today
rather
the way that insurrections are organized
nowadays
is less in uniforms with military
hierarchies and chains of command less
with detailed military plans of battle
and more
through social media and the mass media
that's the era that we're living in in
many cases the communications have
multiple layers
and anyone who knows a teenager is a
teenager or knows anyone in their 20s
knows that hashtags and memes and ways
of communicating among internet
subcultures can mean
that words that could have one meaning a
benign or even a baffling meaning to
large portions of the american public
can carry a very
different significance
to the people swimming in that
particular subculture
so the most important witness
today after professor magliacca
testifies the most powerful witness
against marjorie taylor greene's
candidacy
the most powerful witness in
establishing
that she crossed the line into
engagement of insurrection is marjorie
taylor green herself
you'll hear her words of course on the
stand
what she says and what she doesn't say
you'll also hear what she said in the
past again some of that will be in
somewhat coded or veiled language but
you'll also hear
in some cases
the mask falls and she shows us exactly
what she intended
now she was not on the capitol steps
urging the uh attackers to to breach
police lines and smash through the doors
on january 6. that was not the role that
she played
different figures within this larger
effort had different roles
but what became clear as december turned
into january as
lawful means of preventing the
certification of joe biden were
exhausted as
non-violent even if unlawful means were
exhausted
is that marjorie taylor greene
nonetheless played an important role
and her role even after she took the
oath on january 3rd
to
uphold the constitution and defend it
against all enemies foreign and domestic
it was several fold
to
bring people to dc again not by
providing trains and buses that would
transport them directly
but rather through other means to
contribute in the planning
and to signal that january 6th would be
as she said herself on january 5th
our
1776 moment
a coded phrase with great significance
in fact it turned out to be
an 1861 moment
instead of violence against the foreign
empire as we saw in 1776
she urged and encouraged and helped
facilitate violent resistance to our own
government
our democracy and our constitution
and in doing so she engaged in exactly
the type of conduct
that triggers
disqualification under section 3 of the
14th amendment
which is to say she engaged in
insurrection
thank you
thank you
mr
thank your honor mayor pleads the core
i represent marjorie taylor green
of congress again
in this hearing
and your honor this is a court of law
this is not a political candidate debate
this is not a place for
political hyperbole
it is not a place for political smears
it's a court of law
and what we've just heard
there was not a word
about the
law
what does the 13th dissection 3 of the
third of the 14th amendment mean
what does the word insurrection mean
what does the word engage me
not a word
there was not a word about the first
amendment
that prevents normal political speech
and a hyperbole from being used against
someone
it's not a word
they think they're in the wrong place
well i plan to talk about the law
what does this
mean
this
very serious charge
that has very broad ramifications to the
rights
of representative greene the voters in
her district and our democracy
first
the right to vote is at stake
right here right now
because they want to deny the right to
vote
to the thousands of people in the 14th
district of georgia by having green
removed from the valley
those voters have a right to vote for
the candidate of their choosing
and they have a right to have their vote
counted
now the primary is may 24
absentee ballots have already been
printed
they will be mailed on may the 2nd
and early voting starts on may the 7th
and what is their hope is that there
will be a decision by the secretary of
state
right before the primary
where she is immediately struck from the
ballot
and those people that go into the
polling place
cannot vote for their candidate of their
choice
because by utilizing this procedure
the substantial constitutional and
federal law
violations
that this candidacy challenge
presents cannot be decided by this court
unlike civil court or criminal corps
which will
always prioritize
deciding issues of that magnitude
before being subject to
a trial
before
being penalized
by disqualification
and before the irreparable harm that
will occur if that
occurs
but that's the nature of the procedure
when can representative green raise her
constitutional
defenses like
the evidence you are presenting violates
the first amendment to the constitution
when are we going to be able to litigate
that question
in state court
after she's disqualified after she's
stripped from the ballot maybe after the
primary occurs and she loses well
nobody can vote for her and obviously
loses it
we'll whoop today
okay
how do we recover from that how do we go
back from that
these are these are irrevocable this is
harm to the voters and to the candidate
now second
our democracy is at stake
it should not be it should be the voters
not government employees public
officials judges and lawyers who decide
our elections
voters have a right to vote for the
candidate of their choice
unless there's very compelling legal
not rhetorical
justification for that
third and which is not present here
third
fundamentally first amendment rights are
at stake
not only the right to vote as i've
mentioned or the right to run for office
but also
the challenges we will try to use the
first amendment protected political
speech of representative green as
evidence of quote
engaging in an insurrection earlier in a
few more minutes professor magliocco and
professor mcduck
how are the southern states governed
after lee's surrender
well there were temporary civil
governments put in place uh by president
johnson but then in 1867 congress passed
the military reconstruction acts to
impose essentially martial law on
almost the entire former confederacy
so for example who was governing
virginia during that period a union army
general okay
and when was the 14th amendment section
3 first implemented
so it was first implemented in the
military reconstruction acts
because those acts said that there had
to be new elections throughout the south
to elect conventions that could ratify
the 14th amendment and write new state
constitutions
and so the acts provided that people who
were covered by what it described as
section 3 of the pending amendment
we're not going to be able to vote in
the elections for those conventions and
then
there had to be some means of uh
determining whether people could or
could not vote under that standard okay
um can we please put up exhibit p48
which has been admitted into evidence
already
and done if you could zoom in to the
like upper left so we can see it
professor mcvac i know this is a small
print um but can you see what that is
yes this is an opinion of attorney
general stan mary interpreting the first
and second military reconstruction
when was that
issue this opinion is may 1867. when was
the 14th amendment ratified
in 1868. and where was this printed this
was in the new york times it would have
been widely reprinted in new spaces
across the country
okay great
uh we can put that down um
how widely was section three applied in
the years after the ratification of the
14th amendment
well between 1868 and 1872 it was
implemented many times mostly to remove
state and local officials who had been
part of the confederacy but also in a
couple instances to exclude people from
from office
and
what led to it not being implemented as
much so in 1872 congress exercised its
power under section 3 to grant an
amnesty to many of the former
confederates
um
basically in part that was because there
had been private bills that had been
giving amnesty to individuals but
largely that was simply did you know a
member of congress
and then if you did they would pass a
bill for you your honor i moved to
strike his first statement it was a
legal opinion and that is whether the
amnesty act of 1872
uh
removed uh gave amnesty to former
only if you will former officers it's a
legal question
i understand i understand grace the
issue i'm going to understand
thank you i mean i understand the point
believe me i understand
what did the debates around amnesty
in public and in the streets or in
congress center on
well
there's a lack of foundation
okay all right we've got to have a
little foundation how familiar are you
with the debates that led to the 1872
msdf i'm quite familiar with them i read
all of them
and what did they focus on
well they focused on whether people
deserved amnesty first of all and second
if so who should be excluded from that
um and basically would it be good for
sectional reconciliation or not a little
bit of big questions and how much of
those debates centered around
ex-confederates as compared to anyone
else who might become subject to section
three well it was basically about
ex-confederates because those were the
people who were petitioning congress for
amnesty
great just a few more questions
during the civil war itself how did
washington dc fare
well it was a fortified city
and for good reason because there was a
confederate attack by uh drupal early
on the capitol in 1864 that was repulsed
at fort monroe
and were there or how many if any
presidential elections occurred during
the civil war
one in 1864. how orderly was that if you
know it was very orderly
uh and how did the counting of the
electoral votes proceed
and there was no problem with it at all
when if ever did the confederate
insurrectionist seize control of the
united states capital they did not
and in your opinion if in 1864 or 1868 a
violent mass of people had seized
control of the us capital during
certification of presidential electoral
votes and disrupted the peaceful
transfer of power would 19th century
americans have understood you stop that
question
thank you your honor i have no further
questions
about it
uh no no your honor not other
the thought crossed my mind yeah
and uh and i was a history major
uh
so maybe i can sort myself in
thank you very much thank you
your honor the petitioners call marjorie
taylor green to the stand
please
thank you um
good morning uh representative greene
i'm andy shelley i represent the
plaintiffs in this matter
um ms green you were elected to congress
in november of 2020 right
yes and you became a member of congress
on january 3rd 2021 is that correct yes
and when you became a member of congress
you became a member of congress by
virtue of having taken an oath of office
right became a member of congress by
being elected by the people of the 14th
district okay but you actually were
permitted to take your seat in the house
of representatives
because you took an oath of office isn't
that correct i swore and i was on
january 3rd and that oath required you
to swear that you would support and
defend the constitution of the united
states right
and it required you to
swear a note that you would support and
defend the constitution of the united
states against all enemies right
yes
and part of the oath that you took
says that you were going to undertake
that obligation
to defend the constitution against all
enemies
freely
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion do you recall that
part
i think so okay well let's have a look
at it this will be uh planets exhibit
63. i just want to make sure you get a
chance to see it
this is the excerpt from the
congressional record
um no you're right this is um which one
this is exhibit px63 this is uh a
federal statute um
five usc 3331 which sets forth the oath
of office for federal officers including
members of congress
and as well as if you can make that a
little bit bigger i want to make sure
the representative can see it
the highlighted portion please
so if you see about a third of the way
two thirds of the way down says that i
will i will take this obligation i take
this obligation freely without any
mental reservation or purpose of evasion
see that
and and you now recall that was part of
the oath right
and what did that mean to you uh
congresswoman green
about taking it freely without
reservation yes
it it means i'm swearing the oath and
i have no reservation great now one part
of the constitution representative
greene is the 12th amendment right
yes you're familiar with the 12th
amendment
yes that's the one that provides for the
constitutional process
for counting electoral votes in a
presidential election right
i object uh under the speech and debate
clause she cannot be questioned about
what she does on the floor of congress
for students who are legislative
responsible and i don't intend to ask
any question of that sort your honor i
just want to unders have her
understanding of the constitution this
is a case about
representative greene's state of mind
including her understanding of the oath
and the constitution then i further
object because this case is not about
her state of mind is whether or not she
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
engaged in those conduct i concur and
that's
sustained
next question
ms greene if somebody tried to
unlawfully interfere
with the process of counting the
electoral votes unlawfully
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution wouldn't you agree
does it define that way does it define
that well i'm asking for your
understanding if somebody broke the law
in a way designed to interfere with the
process of counting the electoral count
college votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution
you mean interrupting congress is that
what you're referring to
doing anything unlawfully to interfere
with the process of counting the
electoral votes interrupting congress
like when the democrats interrupted
congress and had a sit-in on the house
floor and stopped congress excuse me
of the debris
could you refresh my question i'm
entitled to ask my questions in the way
i'd like to ask them your honor i ask
that you listen to my question and
simply respond
may i proceed
yes
so if someone broke the law
in an effort to interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution am i right about that
breaking the law is unlawful there's
been over 700 people charged for what
happened on january 6 right and those
people were trying to interfere
with the lawful process of counting the
votes for the electoral college right
i i
i would assume yes they they did they
stopped the electoral count right and so
those people would be enemies of the
constitution you would agree with that
right
i don't know that i don't know i don't
know if it defines it that way
well
having taken the oath that we saw on the
screen
if you were aware that someone was going
to lawfully and unlawfully excuse me
unlawfully interfere with the
constitutional process of counting the
electoral votes you'd be obliged by your
oath to try to stop them right your
honor i i object uh the the client the
claim is not she violated her own the
claim is under section 3 of the 14th
amendment
and so her opinion on words like enemies
are words of art often in
the law
is just irrelevant
to uh to the matter to whether or not
she engaged
did i direct and uh
overtake uh of interruption your honor
we we we had a one-hour presentation on
the law from mr bob we did not object to
that
i will let you answer the question i
forgot what it is can we ask for it to
be right back
okay
question
if you were
aware that somebody was going to
unlawfully
interfere with the constitutional
process of counting electoral votes you
would be obliged
to have them arrested or stopped right
you may answer
you may answer the question to the best
of your bill
i had no knowledge
of any attempt and so that's a question
that i can't answer well i'm
i can't answer that question i i i take
your representation that you had no
knowledge for the for the time being i'm
asking it as a hypothetical question
just to understand
your answer a hypothetical question well
i'm permitted to ask you one so i'm
going to ask you again if you had
knowledge in advance that someone was
going to unlawfully interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes in a
presidential election
under your oath you'd be obliged to do
something to stop that right right
object she's not being charged for
violating her hope there's no pro
foundation laid that she had any
knowledge about anything like that
we'll come to that and so these
sustain
let me try the different way on the
screen remember the part in the oath
where you talked about
taking on the obligations of the oath
freely and without mental reservation or
purpose of evasion you recall that from
a few minutes ago right
yes okay
if you knew
that
people were planning to interfere
with the constitutional process of
counting the electoral votes
you knew that before you took the oath
and you took the oath anyway
and decided not to do anything
about those plans
that would be a mental reservation don't
you agree i object she's not she is not
being charged with violating the elders
the question is does she engage in
insurrection or rebellion
her state of mind is relevant your honor
we think it's very important to have her
understanding what
it's relevant to whether she engaged in
insurrection during the time period from
january 3rd to january 6th and we're
going to be talking about her state of
mind all day you may come back to that
question after you have laid a
foundation for why it ties into her
activities from and after the fair
enough
fair enough your honor
um ms green you're familiar with social
media right
and that's a form of communication right
yes you know what facebook is and
twitter right yeah you use those as an
important form of communication in your
work
yes you post messages on facebook right
i post statements messages yes videos
also right
yes
and you also
respond and react to other people's
comments when they're posted on facebook
or twitter right
yes
and you do that as a way to get your
political views out into the world
it's my freedom of speech to do so i
agree
um and you've been very successful at
using social media to get your your
views out of the world right
i would say that's an opinion well i'm
asking your opinion you've got
hundreds of thousands of people
who follow you
on twitter and facebook right
no not really because my twitter my
personal twitter account
doesn't exist anymore before it was
suspended by twitter
you had hundreds of thousands of people
following you on facebook and twitter
right yeah and by the way
the way facebook and twitter work is my
understanding is they don't have to
necessarily follow you
to read what you have to say right
i guess so so
it could be millions of people who have
read the things that you have said on
facebook and twitter over the years
i don't know that
but it could be you would agree with
that right no i don't know that okay i
don't know how many people read or see
what i post on social media
but what you post on social media is
what you want people to know about your
political beliefs correct
um
sure okay you're not putting stuff up
there as a joke are you
sometimes yes
um well we'll go we'll come back to that
um
and you use facebook and twitter to
to communicate with your constituents in
the 14th congressional district here in
georgia right yes
so
immediately after the 2020 election
and through january 6th and even beyond
that
you issued a number of
tweets and made statements on twitter
and facebook
about the election right
yes you tweeted a whole lot of material
about your views of what happened in the
2020 election yes and
the thrust of those tweets
were that you felt that the election was
stolen from the sitting president i
object that that is
you can ask the question what is your
opinion what is
well i also want to ask whether she
communicated that opinion through
well let's do it that way your honor i i
take your point
where are you going with this counselor
i'm going to show the witness a number
of her tweets and i wanted to make sure
that i understand the context of them
that's all
well she said she posts on twitter right
and my question is whether she posts
material that reflect the opinion that
you have strike that ms green you you
have you had the opinion between
november
2020 when the election happened and
january 6th
2021 that the election was stolen from
president trump
am i right about that
if you've got questions about specific
documents or specific things go ahead
let's not
uh
let's let's go to px2m as well
i'm please which one is this
a 2a your honor
can you see that on the screen
and um what we have here in
2a is a document
um
well i'll ask you um can you tell us
is this a statement that you posted
on twitter
uh
on december 3rd 2020
what
i'll go ahead and go ahead sure
yes ma'am
yes yeah and
this is a
statement where you talk about
um
that you were looking for a senator to
join yourself and representative mo
brooks to reject the fraudulent votes
for joe biden and to keep the real
donald trump in the white house right i
have jack
your honor to
the
you can hear my objection i'm waiting
i'm waiting with bated breath jim all
right uh it is
this violates her right of free speech
there's nothing in this statement
that meets the brand of her test even if
speech could be considered
since it can't when we're dealing with
engages which is conduct not speak
and uh and it does not provide does not
even meet the incitement as
which requires directed to inciting or
producing imminent flawless and action
your honor we heard an hour of argument
this morning on this oh hold on hold on
so thank you honor that is likely to
incite or produce action in the quote so
it's objectionable
and to call her into account for her
first amendment free speech is
unconstitutional
i appreciate your argument but that's
argument i'm going to allow the question
go ahead mr chubb
when you sent out this
strike that did you send out this tweet
as green
as well could you put it back on
yes okay
and when you sent out this tweet you
wanted the people who read the tweet to
know that it was your view
that
the votes for mr biden for president
were fraudulent or some of them were
right
that really wasn't the purpose of that
tweet
i'm just asking whether when you sent
this you were communicating to your the
people who read your twitter account
that you believed that there were
fraudulent votes for mr biden and that
your goal was to keep president trump in
the white house
i was communicating that we were looking
for a senator to join our objection
which is very much
uh part of the
responsibilities and duties
that i can do as a member of congress i
agree with that
but the purpose of that
was because you believed
that the votes for mr biden were
fraudulent right
or at least some of them
we had we had been
spending a vast amount of time
reading and researching and talking to
people
and had seen uh tremendous evidence of
voter fraud i don't know if you're aware
because i know you're not from georgia
we currently have our secretary of state
your honor i would love to strike this
i'm entitled to get answers to my
questions your honor
thank you thank you
all right let's let's back up
by the way
your honor i'm sorry to interrupt we we
missed something very important can the
representative be sworn oh thank you no
i swore oh you did oh okay i didn't see
that i'm sorry
i'm
can i ask the court to acknowledge that
this is a an adverse wisdom witness a
hospital
she's an adverse witness and therefore
cross-examine right even though she
makes on your case and she yes i
acknowledged and
i would ask the court to remind the
witness that in this posture she has to
answer my questions she can't give
speeches
is that fair she's entitled you're
entitled to an answer to the question
that is asked she's not entitled to
major answers you're not entitled to
answers that are
uh that uh to require her to answer when
the question is objectionable violates
the first amendment rights is irrelevant
to the charges that are uh being made
just to
what fishing expedition political
theater what is that this is this is
cross-examination
i'm entitled to a yes no or i can't
answer responses let's go ahead and this
is objectionable
you have a standing objection mr bob
to everything in the world i want to
question your witness let her catch you
oh my god she's doing fine wait a minute
that's another stop
let's probably sit down next question
this is not theater
this is not an argument from the supreme
court this is an evidentiary hearing so
let's get going go ahead mr chairman
um as well as can you pull up
plaintiff's exhibit
2c please
what was which number 2c
the
um
is this a
tweet
that you sent out from your account
on
december 19
2020
yes
and in this tweet um
let me go back a second your honor i
would just ask that
the previous exhibit which i think was
2db um admitted into evidence
i'm sorry 2a all right so 2a is banana
yes
um i'd ask that 2c be admitted into
evidence
2c
all right
say that again i'm distracted go through
it again sure i asked the witness if
this was her tweet she said it was this
is your tweet okay
and i ask that it be admitted into
evidence i object that it's not
probative and it violates her first
amendment right well has nothing to do
with engage it doesn't
work
it's in for what it's worth mr bob okay
i mean i don't mean it's worth anything
but it's in it
and i apologize uh
i do
think it's my responsibility to make
pertinent
i
thank you um representative greene um in
your tweet
december 19th 2020 that we've marked as
plaintiff's exhibit 2c
one of the things you're communicating
to the people who
would read this tweet was that you want
them to come to washington
on january 6th
for a demonstration
is that right
for a march for trump right march
fight for trump
the phrase that you use there
is hashtag fight for trump right that's
what the words say that's what it says
on my tweet okay
and you posted that because you in fact
wanted people to show up
on january 6
2021 in dc
in order to help you
stop
the theft of the 2020 election from your
point of view
now
okay
well i'm not sure we got a clear answer
on this you you did believe at this time
that the 2020 election had been stolen
by the democrats from mr trump right
i i was asking people to come for a
peaceful march which is
what everyone is entitled to do
under their first amendment but i was
not asking them to actively engage in
violence or any type of action
my question is really simple it's about
your opinion
when this tweet came out in this period
it was your opinion that the election
had been stolen from mr trump or was
about to be stolen right
under my opinion there was a tremendous
amount of
fraudulent
things that happened in the election
and under my opinion i want to do
anything i can to protect election
integrity and to protect uh the
the people of my district in georgia
uh people's votes they should count
is it fair to say representative greene
that from election night of 2020
until january 6 2021
your personal opinion and your wish
was that congress not certify
joe biden as the winner of the 2020
election
uh no that's not accurate
uh you you believed that joe biden had
lost the election to mr trump right
well yes we saw a tremendous amount of
voter fraud we have uh investigations
going on right now in the state of
georgia there's investigations going on
in multiple states
my own husband showed up to vote on the
general election and when he went in to
vote in person he was told that he had
already voted by absentee ballot when in
fact he had never even requested an
absentee ballot
we could do this now i understand
there's an i.t issue that requires a
pause okay well should we take how long
do we need
two minutes all right well
everybody
be patient
thank you
your camera was off
good
uh
you want i mean i hate to make it right
just sit around but
let's take a chance
let's come back
oh
let's come
kind of back to 12.
out and get in come back and get well
everybody come back in and let the
parties out come back
[Music]
20 minutes now
you want us to let everybody else out
first
reach down there i apologize
is
well unfortunately uh some technical
issues here with this georgia court
hearing challenging georgia republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green's
candidacy for
re-election a group of voters in her
congressional district filed the
challenge citing a provision in the 14th
amendment of the constitution preventing
members of congress
from running again if they take part in
an insurrection or rebellion against the
government congresswoman greene
as you saw in the midst of testifying
the court here taking a break as they
try to iron out some of the problems
with the equipment there
we will also take a break here resume
our live coverage in just a couple of
minutes and we'll right now show you
some of the testimony some of the
opening statements from earlier in this
case
thank your honor mayor pleads the core
i represent marjorie taylor greene
member of congress
in this hearing
and your honor this is a court of law
this is not a political candidate debate
this is not a place for
political hyperbole
it is not a place for political smear
it's a court of law
and what we just heard
there was not a word
about the law
what does the 13th does section 3 of the
third of the 14th amendment mean
what does the word insurrection mean
what does the word engage me not a word
it was not a word about the first
amendment
that prevents normal political speech
and a hyperbole from being used against
someone
it's not a word
they think they're in the wrong place
well i plan to talk about the law
what does this
mean
this
very serious charge
that has
very broad ramifications to the rights
of representative greene the voters in
her district and our democracy
first the right to vote is at stake
right here right now
because they want to deny the right to
vote
to the thousands of people in the 14th
district of georgia by having green
removed from the valley
those voters have a right to vote for
the candidate of their choosing
and they have a right to have their vote
counted
now the primary is may 24. absentee
ballots have already been printed
they will be mailed on may the second
and early voting starts on may the 7th
and what is their hope is that there
will be a decision by the secretary of
state
right before the primary
where she is immediately struck from the
ballot
and those people that go into the
polling place
cannot vote for their candidate of their
choice
because by utilizing this procedure
the substantial constitutional and
federal law
violations
that this candidacy challenge
presents
cannot be decided by this court
unlike civil court or criminal corps
which will
always prioritize
deciding issues of that magnitude
before being subject to
a trial
before
being penalized
by disqualification
and before the irreparable harm that
will occur if that occurs
but that's the nature of the procedure
when can representative green raise her
constitutional
defenses like
the evidence you are presenting violates
the first amendment to the constitution
when are we going to be able to litigate
that question
in state court
after she's disqualified after she's
stripped from the ballot maybe after the
primary occurs and she loses well see
nobody can vote for her and obviously
loses it
will whoop today
okay how do we recover from that how do
we go back from that
these are
these are irrevocable this is
harm to the voters and to the candidate
now second our democracy is at stake
it should not be it should be the voters
not government employees public
officials judges and lawyers who decide
our elections
voters have a right to vote for the
candidate of their choice
unless there's very compelling legal
not rhetorical
justification for
that third and which is not present here
third
fundamentally first amendment rights are
at stake
not only the right to vote as i've
mentioned or the right to run for office
but also
the challengers will try to use
the first amendment protected political
speech of representative green as
evidence of quote
engaging in an insurrection or rebellion
that's unconstitutional and should not
be allowed
and finally
the charge not only triggers
disqualification
but is a serious federal criminal
offence
that she is being charged with
now this is a very serious matter and
the decision should be based on
admissible evidence under the rules
we are
we recognize you have greater
latitude than that
but
the the charges the seriousness of the
charges we think warrant that adherence
and faithful application of the law
and we expect you
that you will do that
now procedure
georgia law and here i am talking about
the law
georgia law
21-2-5 permits a candidate challenge
under two circumstances one
a candidate a candidate is not qualified
to be a candidate
all right
and number two
is a candidate is not qualified to take
office
of course these are different
different conceptually and different in
their application
so a claim under
section 3 of the 14th amendment has to
do with
what your your ability to take office
because it not
it doesn't address candidacy in any way
it's the ability of a representative in
this case to take office
because
she has
sworn the oath of office
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
congress has not
given her amnesty
and finally she when she presents
herself
to take the oath of office she could be
challenged
which we think is the exclusive
constitutional right of congress not
state officials to decide
whether or not she is eligible at that
time to take office
so we're not dealing with a candidacy
disqualification we're dealing with a
alleged take office qualification
now uh
unfortunately as i mentioned
many of these issues cannot be decided
by this court
even though you might make
recommendations of the secretary of
state on the map
and we have fully briefed this already
in our motion to dismiss and to stay the
proceedings
the
constitutional claims the federal law
claims the protections of the first
amendment speech and debate
and what these
uh words in section three
mean
so let's look at that
we have our we
admitted evidence is r2 which is the
14th amendment and it includes of course
section 3.
and section 3 provides
that no person shall be a senator or
representative in congress
etc etc etc who
having previously taken an oath as a
member of congress for an officer of the
united states executive
to support the constitution shall
have engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the same
or given aid and comfort to the enemies
thereof
so there's a sequence
you have to have originally taken the
ill
you have to then engage
and then you can't you are disqualified
and uh congress can determine that
you're disqualified for having done that
from taking a subsequent vote
and therefore cannot assume your your
position as a member of congress
and then furthermore but congress may by
a vote of two-thirds of each house
remove such disability
and of course that's the
various amnesty acts that have been
adopted or could be adopted by by
congress
now this
provision
as i mentioned makes it clear this is
about eligibility on january 3rd
2023
not today
not tomorrow
but eligibility when she presents
herself as a re-elected member of
congress
she could be
excluded under the exclusive power of
congress to judge the qualifications of
its members
that's
where these people should be
in congress
explaining why she once she is reelected
is disqualified
from taking her seat
now
the second thing that makes is this
sequence makes clear
is that
in her case she took the office first
the further first time
and these are in our stipulated backs
right
uh on january the 3rd that's that's the
first time
and so she would have had to engage in
insurrection or rebellion after january
3rd
in other words under the
the constitution
prior to january 3rd
she could have done
done it
under the law
now it's preposterous that she would
even consider us
she
she
she
reveres the united states constitution
but
the way the statute or the
constitutional provision is set up
she would have to have engaged after
so
evidence of anything she did prior to
june and january 3rd is just
completely irrelevant to the section 3.
unless it is direct a direct admission
of her intention to engage in
insurrection or rebellion after january
3rd
anything else she says is not only it
should be excluded because it doesn't
fit the the charge right
but as i will soon demonstrate it is
protected by the first amendment
now here
words matter
at every turn the challengers mistake
what the law is in their complaint
obviously they didn't discuss it here
but in their complaint
and calling something something
doesn't make it something calling a
orange an apple does not make the orange
an apple
an orange has characteristics
that
are pre-established
and are applied to determine whether the
word apple
applies
here
the key phrases in
section 3 are themselves
defined
by the law
now
they start off
in misstating the law
by saying
that
representative greene should be
disqualified under section three this is
also called by the way the
disqualification club
uh
because she is someone who quote aided
and engaged
in an insurrection and a quote
complaint
page one
aided and engaged
where is that in section three
it says engage in insurrection or
rebellion or
gave aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof
there's no aided
and engaged in this in this
in this statute
now each of those phrases
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
that phrase and and is four
accompanying uh
praise gives aid or comfort to the enemy
zero
each of those have special meaning
engage is
an act
it is
a direct and overt act
of
insurrection it is about as one
commentator said domestic war
that's what engaged in insurrection
rebellion is
about
the or
giving aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof
as the same commentator said is about
foreign wars
each of these phrases have been used
several times in federal law
and have come to
a gain
particular meaning their words of art
so you can't take
aid
out of the second part
about foreign wars
and add it to the first part that is
about domestic wars
that defies the rules of construction it
flaunts the
technical and
meaning of those phrases of those words
so what is engaged and what does it mean
well engage connotes conduct
a direct over act of
insurrection to overthrow the united
states government
it is about things like
which the people who drafted this well
understood many of them were
part of the victorious thank the lord
union army
and they they knew what an insurrection
or rebellion was so it was taking up
arms voluntarily joining the confederate
army it was about
working in the war department
for the confederate government
it was about
providing supplies and equipment and
material for the
people who
were conducting the war
so these were
direct overt acts of insurrection
now
instead of
looking to that
what we have already heard
described as their evidence and and of
course as well revealed in their
complaint
they want us they want to hold against
her first amendment protective speech
and here's a few examples
on
page 19
quote the people will remember the
patriots who stood for election
integrity on the end of quote
that is supposed to be
about an insurrection or engaging in an
insurrection
or they said she said she's alleged to
have said
uh quote congress is the last line of
defense
from a stolen election end of quote on
page 21.
isn't that quintessential political
speech isn't that recognizing the role
of congress and certifying the electors
how could that be interpreted as
in
as an overt act to engage in
insurrection or redundant
well
it can't be
and
now
the question of voter fraud in the 2020
election
it was a is a quintessential example
of political speech
legitimate political disagreements
about what happened
yeah you know the supreme court in
republican party in minnesota versus
white but actually the first one i
argued
in the court
said that announcing
views on disputed legal or political
issues is at the core of the first
amendment
at the core
now this is
disputed
no question
but
but to say that is an act of
insurrection it is a
direct overt act of insurrection against
the united states
when jet lag representative green was an
elected member of congress who on
january 6 had a constitutional duty and
responsibility to be on the floor where
she was
to determine whether or not
certain votes uh electoral votes from
trump's the states would be certified
now this the first amendment demands a
very narrow test
i've already said
and argued that engage
is connote's conduct
but we can look to
a
much broader term that actually allows
speech to be considered
and that is the brandenburg case in the
naacp case which we saw
and that is the word in uh incitement
now
incitement and
engage are different words with
different meanings
and in fact you know that for sure
because there are federal statutes that
that say
inside
and then say engage in certain conduct
i mean they're used as different words
right
incitement the supreme court has said is
speech
but
the supreme court because of first
amendment concerns so that
normal everyday political speech
will not be punished
as they want to do
says that is that
that speech
must be
quote directed to inciting or producing
producing imminent lawless action
and that it is likely to incite
or produce such action and quote that's
on page
30 of our motion to dismiss
that is very respectable
[Music]
everybody ready good okay we're back
from the record
we appreciate your patience your
disruption appreciate everybody's
cooperation
with technology one of those things
all right
yeah procedure on it
your honor i would just ask that mr bob
not consult with his client in the break
period while i'm examining her that's
generally not permitted
in my experience
go ahead
um can we see uh plaintiff's exhibit 2c
pleasing as well
so 2c
ms green this is a tweet that we talked
about a little bit earlier just a quick
question on it
you issued this on
um
december 19th 2020 correct
i can't see real well but i think that's
the date maybe maybe we can make it a
little larger
that's what it says
and
what you were doing in this
tweet was you were
tweeting out a story
from the epic times
about president trump saying that the
protests that were planned for january
6th were going to be quote wild right i
object we don't have the
where's the article right there under
the picture under the picture of
president trump does it quote that yes
it says trump trump call in supporters
should join wild protest in d.c on jan
six okay i was thrown by jackson
you can answer the question
representative green what was your
question my question is what you were
doing in this tweet is you were tweeting
out a story
from the epic times
about president trump making a statement
that the protest on january 6th
would be wild
right
i tweeted an article that had the
details of the dates and times right and
also included president trump's
statements that he expected the
demonstrations on january 6 to be wild
right
i don't think that's what my tweet was
about okay well but you see that the
article says trump colon supporters
should join quote wild protests in dc
on jan 6.
i don't remember tweeting that
specifically for what you're saying
those are your words
no
i'm actually reading from what's on
you're speculating on why i tweeted that
but i don't remember tweeting it for
that specific reason is green i'm just
asking questions i'm just answering
and
in your tweet you mentioned earlier that
um
your words join
march for trump and dc on january 6 to
fight for trump that you were urging
people to come to washington for a
peaceful demonstration right
peaceful demonstration right absolutely
yeah that word peaceful is nowhere in
this tweet right
have a look that word peaceful is not in
the street there is only half of it
there let's let's get give the
representative a paper copy of that one
just want to make sure i'm not going to
see it now it was scrolled up just a
second ago okay peaceful is not in there
is it
um
well you know like is the word peaceful
in there miss green does not say
peaceful right my question but you're
asking me and i said for peaceful
demonstration
just like people have the right to do in
their first amendment i i'm asking you
didn't there's not a secret code in
there that's supposed to be peaceful
right well i never mean anything for
violence i don't support violence of any
kind and i've said it over and over
again
so i i'm telling you you just didn't say
it on this occasion did you i never mean
anything for violence
all of my words never ever mean anything
for violence we'll we'll examine that
question go to uh planets exhibit two f
please
two
f f is in frank yes
and
i'm looking at
um yes this top half of the exhibit
ms green this is a tweet that you sent
out
on january 2nd 2021 correct
i'm not sure
okay you don't recall this
i i don't recall tweeting that no okay
um you can set that to one side
well let me ask this question
does anybody
tweet things on your twitter account
it's like that did anybody in january of
2021 tweet things on your twitter
account without your permission
on what day
anytime from
november of 2020 to january 6th
i don't remember that's difficult to
answer okay which you'd be surprised if
somebody got into your twitter account
and tweeted something without your
permission wouldn't you
well no one tweeted anything without my
permission i just don't remember
who tweeted what
fair enough
now
would you agree miss green that
this tweet
from january 2nd 2021
is something that we can fairly
attribute to you being that it was
tweeted on your twitter account
i
i'm sorry i
i don't know
okay
you take that down
the screen you've had your disagreements
with speaker pelosi isn't that right
i'm not sure what you mean you've had
political disagreements with her you
don't agree with some of the things
she's done in her career right
politically speaking that would be
correct right you don't agree with a lot
of things she's done right
politically speaking that would be
correct in fact you think that speaker
pelosi is a traitor to the country right
uh you're i'm not answering that
question it's speculation you've said
that haven't you miss green that she's a
trader to the country no i haven't said
that okay
put up planets exhibit five please
oh no wait
hold on now i believe
by not upholding the uh securing the
border
that that violates
her oath of office
fair enough i'm i'm not interested in
her oath of office i'm interested in
that you said
that she's a traitor to our country
right i object your honor she is uh this
is i don't think the relevance of that
mr chilly
your honor can we give mr bap a standing
objection on the first amendment grounds
because this is this is a this is an
effort to interrupt my examination of
the witness
i am attempting to establish
the
the
the witnesses
desire
to engage in insurrection
during the period january third to
january sixth now it's true that some of
the things that she said are relevant if
they were even though they occurred
before january third but there's no
first amendment objection to evidence
your honor she's she said what she said
there is first amendment
we don't agree well
but i get to make my objection you can
make the objection you can have a
standing objection
because he wants to interrupt my flow
you're right that's not appropriate i
don't reject everything okay okay i have
specific things that i think i object to
and i
should be extended the courtesy to do
that you may you may have checked
but uh plants exhibit five please we're
on five now
okay
um
so i'm placing before you um what we
pre-marketed plants exhibit five which
is an article that appeared in cnn on
january 26
uh 2021.
a hard copy of this
should be in the book
i mean did she have a hard copy i mean
she can't read it off the screen um we
we have one for her
let's start using hard copies you can't
read stuff like this on the screen may i
approach the witness yes
you have a standing permission approach
witness to deliver copies of documents
that you estimate you're going can ask
your question thank you
as well if you could scroll down a bit
one second
so
so
mrs green i want to um direct your
attention to the bottom of
the fourth page of the exhibit
this is this is a paragraph that starts
out
she's a traitor to our country do you
see that
i object you honor what possible
relevance could it be
that they she had political
disagreements that resulted in hyperbole
that is commonly used your honor this is
an argument
thanks thank you
i just want to ask a narrow question
representative green
did you say
referring to speaker pelosi
she's a traitor to our country
she's guilty of treason she took an oath
to protect the american citizens
she gives aid and comfort to our enemies
who illegally invade our land that's
what treason is
and our law representatives and senators
can be kicked out and no longer serve in
our government
and it's uh a crime punishable by death
is what treason is nancy pelosi is
guilty of treason did you say those
words
i said this is what i was telling you is
i
she doesn't uphold our laws uh it's a
simple yes or no question ma'am did you
say those words
without being instructed by him to say
yes or no i don't agree your honor this
is cross-examination she's so entitled
to an answer to my question not a speech
did you say these words that are quoted
on the bible did you say that
according to the cnn article i did i
don't remember you recall saying i don't
recall saying all of this but i do i do
recall having said this about the
i totally disagree with the border
issues okay
next question okay
um
and representative green you you have
advocated
the use of physical violence
against people you disagree with
politically right i object without
contacts without uh anything
uh overall go ahead
what's the question again mr speaker
you've advocated the use of physical
violence against people that you
disagree with politically that's a
question yes
is that true
i don't think so i don't know how to
answer that next question
well um have a look at what we've marked
as plaintiff's exhibit
five
e5 q5
that's the same
same one okay thank you
you've got a copy of this representative
oh is it
okay
and
well let me ask a foundational question
um
you understand that
on social media posts like facebook and
twitter
uh one of the things well i guess on
facebook one of the things you can do is
you can like someone's post right
you can like people's
post right
and when you like someone's post that's
a way of signifying that you agree
with or admire or think is cr it's
correct that the post is correct right
uh i don't know i don't agree with your
phrase or questioning well i'm asking
you
isn't it true that when you like when
you personally miss green like someone's
post you're signifying your approval for
what the post said no i don't agree with
the how you're phrasing that question no
i don't agree with that
um so
it's true though that you liked a post
that suggested that quote a bullet to
the head of
nancy pelosi would be a quicker way to
remove her as speaker of the house than
impeachment right now you're using a cnn
article which has lot cnn has lied about
me multiple times and you're using a cnn
did you like the post answer my question
did you like a post that said it's
quicker that a bullet to the head would
be a quicker way to remove nancy pelosi
from the role of the speaker i've had
many people manage my social media
account over the years i have no idea
who liked that okay
you're
are you testifying under oath it wasn't
you just want to be clear on that
oh my god oh my god hold on
we just lost a key moment let's get back
on
next next question
she won't answer
he's not gonna answer guys
it was ted cruz who liked it
by the way you know ms green that
one of the places inside the united
states capitol building
that was invaded by people who were
doing violence was miss pelosi's office
right
i was inside the chamber
during uh on january 6 so i do not know
all the places that those people went i
only know where i was
are you telling us that in the
more than a year since these events
occurred
you have not become aware that one of
the offices that was invaded by people
who were illegally in the capital
was nancy pelosi's office no idea
wow
now you mentioned earlier in response to
some of my questions that there was a
demonstration
uh that was being planned for
january 6 2021 called the march for
trump right
we talked about it on one of my twitter
posts right and and that demonstration
was being organized in part
by an organization called women for
america right
i don't remember who organized it okay
um
mr can you pull up um plaintiff's
exhibit 2d
i'm sorry which one was it i'm sorry 2d
right this is just the best
b isn't bored no no d is a dog
has there been any perjury so far i
missed it
there's been plenty okay good
and they didn't have lunch yet right
there was just a short break and then
they're doing lunch a document that's
been pre-marked as plaintiff's exhibit
2d
um
just begin by asking
um
let's take a break lunch is here
one of the things that you can do on
twitter
mrs green is you can retweet or send out
again
somebody else's tweet right
okay
and
on plaintiffs 2d
which i've placed in front of you
you are retweeting a tweet
sent by kylie jane cremer
on december 19 2020 right
i don't know if i retweeted it well if
you look carefully it says marge
retailer green there's an american flag
and it says retweet it as your testimony
i retweeted it you know you don't recall
one way or the other i don't recall
and it's your testimony that if this got
retweeted from your account that would
have been done with your permission
right
i don't i don't recall retweeting it
that's not my question you you don't
deny
that
kylie jane cremer's
message was retweeted from your account
in the form set forth as planus 2d
in
on december 20th
2020. i'm sorry december 19.
you don't deny that do you
this is what your picture has this paper
has i don't have this twitter account
anymore
so i don't recall i don't remember
retweeting this okay but you do remember
that there was this thing called the
march for trump it was going to be on
january 6th right
yes and that women for america were one
of the organizers right
i don't remember but that's what this
says
okay
um
and one of the other
hashtags
for
the demonstrations that were planned on
january 6
2021 in washington dc
um was a hashtag
stop the steal hashtag stop this deal
right
yes yes
and
another hashtag that got used at the
time
was or i'm sorry a website that was
being used to organize people to come to
washington was something called
wildprotest.com
right
i don't know what a nasty woman
let's have a look at um px33 please
i'm sorry again this is jelly p
px33 xpx i call it px p33 p33
oh my gosh i'm sorry
please proceed governor
i've placed
before you miss green
a document that was marked as
plaintiff's exhibit or petitioners
exhibit 33. you can tell she would never
lie because she has a cross hanging from
her neck
does this refresh your recollection that
there was a website known as
wildprotest.com
that was
encouraging people to come to washington
for a process protest on january 6th i
don't remember the website but i'm
seeing it here on this
on your
paper
and
wild was the term that president trump
used to describe what he thought was
going to happen on january 6th right
don't remember
wild is also a term that high schoolers
use when they talk about spring break
fair enough
and it was wild
but
whatever the
title of the demonstration or the name
or the hashtag that was used you would
agree that you were aware
in
after the election and before january 6
that people were being asked to come to
dc
for a large demonstration to object to
the certification of joe biden as
president of the united states right i
was aware people were coming to support
our objection in congress that on
january 6th the only thing i was
preparing for was objecting
when when did you first
become aware that there were going to be
large demonstrations in dc on the 6th i
don't recall
did you consider at any point
participating in any of those
demonstrations
it was put on my calendar but then i
never went if we were too busy we were
you know looking at all the evidence and
preparing for our debates and there was
so much evidence that she was busy on
your calendar
i don't know
somebody on your staff i take it
i have no idea who has access to a
complete stranger right it was somebody
from your congressional staff right
probably so but i have no idea and
as you sit here
can you tell us
why it is that
a an appearance for you at that
demonstration was placed on your
calendar
can you rephrase that question how did
it come to pass that
it was put on your calendar that you
were going to appear at a demonstration
why was it on your account too busy
i don't know i was so busy just
preparing to object i don't know
um you were going to
go to one of these demonstrations as a
speaker right
i don't think so i was always preparing
to object we were very busy
well have a look at what we've marked as
number around 33
and if you go about
three pages in at the bottom of that
page and then over to the next page
it says invited speakers and featured
guests right
[Applause]
i'm assuming i guess i was on there
because i was invited right i don't i
don't know who made this website i i'm
sorry i can't answer okay well if you
say anything about it
well you can answer that that's your
name and face right
that is my name and face but i again i
don't run that website we know your face
marjorie
my question to you representative green
is
did some you or someone under your
authority at your congressional office
authorize
you to be placed as a speaker or guest
of the wild protest demonstration i get
many invitations as a member of congress
not the question
and all kinds of speaking engagements
most of the time those go on my calendar
but they have no relevance as to whether
i attend or not so would it be fair to
say ms greene
that through your office
you authorized your name
and your
likeness to be associated with the
wildprotest.com
demonstration no you cannot say that or
assume that
that would be whoever organized this
he is so vile
going back to 33.
you know aly alexander don't you
no i don't really know him
when you say you don't really know him
you've met him right i've seen him
before but i don't know him
how many times have you been in his
physical presence to your knowledge
i cannot even guess hardly any
10
20 no
have you shaking his hand
i've shaken his hand before yes i shake
hands with
pretty much everyone i mean lots of
people right um
and he's a friend of yours right now
okay
we'll come back to that
we'll come
i definitely didn't meet him more than
10 times and i did shake his hand the
idea of you coming to appear at a
demonstration on january 6th i do not
recall that now you're not denying that
happening you just don't recall one way
or the other i do not recall that now
okay
um
well did you discuss with anybody
attending the wild protest demonstration
that was planned for january 6th i do
not recall ever talking about attending
other than people
um
on your
congressional staff or your campaign
staff
list for me all the people who you spoke
to
about the demonstrations on january 6th
that would i i'm sorry i have no idea
okay you don't remember any of them i do
not remember not any of them no okay
and
you spoke to some people about those
demonstrations prior to being sworn in
as a representative from the 14th
district right
i i don't remember and you spoke to some
of those people
after you took the oath on january 3rd
and before the 6th right i don't
remember
did you speak to anybody in government
about the fact that there were going to
be demonstrations in washington on
january 6th
i don't remember we were mostly reading
information about election fraud and
people's side i was reading my bible
about what they'd witnessed with voter
fraud and preparing to object that was
pretty much all i remember doing
pretty much but your testimony as you
sit here today under oath is that you
didn't talk to anybody in government
about the fact that there were going to
be large protests in washington
on january 6th i don't remember
he spoke to representative biggs
or his staff about that fact didn't you
i do not remember
how about representative gosar
i'm sorry i don't remember
did you talk to people at the white
house about the fact that there were
going to be large okay so for our
lawyers in the audience please let me
know how can how can these other lawyers
pierce this not remembering anything
prior to january 6 representative greene
did anyone ever mention to you the
possibility
that there might be violence
in washington on january 6 2021
i don't remember
so it's possible that folks told you
things could get violent in washington
on january 6th right
i was a brand new member of congress if
i don't remember those conversations but
i would hope nancy pelosi and those in
charge of the capital were taking the uh
capital security very seriously
my question is just about
whether anybody at all ever mentioned to
you the possibility of violence i don't
remember okay so you're not denying it
you're just saying you don't recall i
don't recall
you don't recall that
people said
you know we're having these big
demonstrations in washington
and some of the people who come to those
demonstrations
might become violent
that never happened the only violence
i'd ever seen was antifa and blm riots
and i've been to so many trump rallies i
have never once seen violence out of
trump people i don't recall any talk of
violence and you knew that the people
who were coming to the demonstrations on
january 6th those were trump people
right
i knew there were many people coming to
support president trump and our
objection on january 6th right and
at least some of them were coming
because you asked them to come right
i didn't purse i don't recall personally
asking people to come but evidently i
tweeted about
uh january 6.
did anybody um strike that
did you have any conversations with
anybody
in government representatives
senators
white house staff the president united
states at the time
any government official or government
employee about the fact
this is now prior to january 6
about the fact that there was a risk
that people coming to washington for
january 6 demonstrations might become
violent i object that's the fourth time
he's asked this i object
it's not the same question
this
really is the same question
what do you ask questions last time
i don't i don't
recall did you ever hear that um
from any source prior to january 6 that
some folks were planning to come
to washington on january 6th and the
idea was that they were going to flood
the capital with people
no i don't remember ever hearing that
okay
you never discuss that with anybody
no i do not remember that
um
are there
tapes but you supported the idea of
people coming to washington on january
6th and flooding the capitol right
no i support people's first amendment
to have a peaceful protest use their
amendments well previously you've
publicly said
that one way for people to express their
displeasure with their government would
be to flood the capitol building with
people right
the capitol belongs to the people they
that's where you come and speak to your
senators your representatives
you you come to express your views you
come to talk about how you want your tax
dollars spent you come to talk about how
you want senators or representatives to
vote
my question is a bit more narrow than
that
you publicly expressed support for the
idea
that people should come to washington to
express their displeasure with their
government
by flooding the capitol
move on um can we have um
px23 please uh oh px23 is a doozy
sir may i approach the witness
i hope they keep her on for hours
the screen i've placed in front of you
what we've previously marked as
petitioners exhibit 23 which is a
cnn article
[Music]
entitled um
cnn's funny in 2019 marjorie taylor
green told protesters to flood the
capital and feel free to abuse violence
she this is
2019.
how many years back high school
do we have to be treated with statements
that like fled the capital fled the
capitol in your
thank you i think the judge is saying
this isn't going well for them
i want to direct your attention
representative greene to the second page
of the complainants that is shelley
could you could you please go through
the proper things
so she knows what she's looking at
yes
i thought i did but i didn't hear it i'm
sorry okay
miss green this is an article that
appeared
we believe in
on cnn
in the wake of january 6th i ask if
you've seen this document before
um nope i haven't seen it yeah
well i'm going to ask some questions
about statements that are attributed to
you in this article you can tell me
whether you made them or not okay
the second page of the document
has a quotation that reads quote all of
us together when we rise up we can end
all of this we can end it
we can do it peacefully we can i hope we
don't have to do it the other way i hope
not
but we should feel like we will if we
have to he doesn't remember saying that
we are the american people now you
recall making that statement
in 2019
in connection with a protest around
fund the wall
no i don't recall
oh my god
are you denying that you made that
statement i'm saying i don't i don't
recall okay you're not denying it you
just don't recall it said
cnn she said she does not recall that is
the answer let's move on
oh boy
yeah maybe starting to ask questions
about things she does recall would be
interesting
let's take a break lunch is here
i i am looking forward to lunch break i
i want to make a turkey sandwich
now further further up please yeah keep
going
i'm sorry judge i think i i'm missing a
page in my copy of the exhibit okay
going
um i'm sorry bottom of yeah
all right thank you that you can saw
everything
uh a little further along in the article
i'm going to ask you whether you made
this this comment
um
if we have a sea of people we will shut
down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building go inside these are public
buildings we own them we own these
buildings do you understand that we own
the buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings
did you say that in connection with the
fund the wall
demonstration in february of 2019. and
because it's about the fun the wall
demonstration i knocked the uh
after she was sworn in as a member of
congress and taken
completely irrelevant
to what she it
getting some good objections now i don't
recall you're using cnn and they've
chopped up my words so many times
they've lied about me so many times i
mean
you sound like you have as many
conspiracy theories as q and on at this
point well you believe in you
i
no i did i did not say i believe in q
anon you you don't believe in q and this
is not relevant
honor q uh-oh
px 84 please as well which one 84 84.
did she open the door to q anon
questions
is that your uh face mrs green
is that your face it appears to me
she's all hopped up on adrenal chrome
ask that you played it's about a minute
50 seconds
and simply ask if
that's you making those statements uh
governor before he starts running this
uh i want
i object unless he assures us that this
is the complete
clip it's hard to say it wasn't you when
it's video
we haven't touched it your honor okay
i'm not saying you touched it right well
this is on
that you're prepared to play this
i think your responsibility and i'm
asking the court to require this or
object
is to make sure that this is not taken
out of context you want to present it as
evidence here we go you should be
required to explain that this is the
entire statement that was it's mistaken
identity judge he's out of context may i
be heard on this your honor sure of
course go ahead your honor
we have been denied the opportunity to
conduct discovery in this case as your
honor knows given the speed with which
this proceeding had to go forward we
have been denied the opportunity to
issue subpoenas to get records to do
precisely what mr bob would like me to
do in fact mr bob objected to all of
those things and said we don't want them
to do those things so the idea now that
he is objecting to us playing a portion
of his own client's words she can defend
herself quite ably she will tell us if
it's out of context or if it's q anon or
something else
first of all
what is this again this is a video we
believe
of the congresswoman making a statement
and where did it come from it came from
uh the the cnn article links to it
uh from facebook
so this is but this was pulled off of
what the internet
well it was it was connected through
it's from the internet
no throwing the hell out of here from a
tweet next question
this is the complete
that's what was there that's what was
there yes okay have you made any
alterations no sir are you aware of any
option no sir
okay do we know when it was made
we believe it was made in february of
2019 but i think you can now ask the
witnesses about it beautiful can we play
the video play the clip
are we going to be able to hear it
in washington dc on february 23rd and
protest and march with me at 8 a.m
really please i'm begging you
if we have
i okay if we have a sea of people if we
shut down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building flood all the government
buildings go inside these are public
buildings we own them
we own these buildings
do you understand that we own the
buildings and we pay all the people that
work in the buildings you know what
february 23rd may be kind of cold we're
going to go inside we're going to be
warm
and then we're going to demand that our
federal government serve we the people
because we're sick and tired of their
ways
we're sick and tired of the corruption
see here's the issue
here's the issue america they think that
we're stupid and they treat us like
we're stupid and we allow it we allow it
well no more we're not going to allow it
any more
we want
solutions to the problems we want to
take care of america america is first
americans come first with americans
taxpayer dollars
we're done
we're done
and we have a massive list of grievances
okay we have a huge list of grievances
and that's why on february 23rd
in washington dc at 8 am i'm not sure if
that's me
and i am telling you to get your butt
there i'm begging all of you to be there
but be there let's make this huge
there's a lot of really really great
people organizing this
you don't even know
it's green that's you right that's me
and and in that clip you were urging
people to come to washington and flood
the capitol right
what year was that
you tell me in the screen i believe it
was for february 23
2019 right there was no violence that
day we peacefully protested fair enough
but my point is to ask you the question
you were urging people for that
demonstration to flood the country to
peacefully protest with me and enter the
capitol and and ask our lawmakers to
serve the american people
[Music]
so now you remember giving that
statement right
now that we've watched the video i'll
remember that now that your memory has
been jogged a little bit do you remember
talking about that demonstration
being done on a peaceful basis
that demonstration was peaceful right
and you remember that you said we can do
it peacefully right of course i only
believe in peaceful demonstrations i do
not support violence
in fact what you said is we can do it
peacefully we can
i hope we don't have to do it the other
way i hope not but we should feel like
we will
if we have to
because we are the american people that
was another statement that you made in
the same presentation right that was in
your cnn article and i don't trust cnn
as a source they've lied about me like
multiple times are you denying that
under oath that you made that statement
i'm not i just don't recall i'm not
recalling saying specifically that uh
the demonstration was peaceful history
shows that
what year was this again 2019 it has
nothing to do with january 6.
i'll move on your honor you're pushing
the envelope
um
i thought she he already fallen off the
cliff
no comments yeah i i'd appreciate if mr
bob would keep his humor to himself in
the moment
he can do that in the cameras outside
when the time comes
gentlemen
i'm serious we need to we need to
we need to
get back to task
ms green did you or any member of your
government or campaign staff
communicate
with anthony aguero
events of january 6. oh boy
i don't recall
did you or any member of your staff
either congressional staff or campaign
staff communicate with somebody named
dustin stockton
prior to january 6th i don't think i
know who that is okay
how about jennifer lawrence not the
actress
but hey jennifer lawrence was involved
in conservative politics did you or any
member of your congressional campaign
staff communicate with ms lawrence
prior to january 6th about the
demonstrations that were planned for
that day i don't recall i don't think i
know who that is
doesn't remember a damn thing
did you or any member of your campaign
or congressional staff ms greene
provide any support
for any demonstrations that occurred on
january 6 2021
i i have no idea i don't think so i
don't know
did you or any member of your staff
provide information advice
funds printed material the promise of a
public statement
to withhold a public statement anything
along those lines
in connection with the demonstrations
that were planned for january 6th
i don't remember i don't think so
and if somebody were to come in here and
say oh yeah she gave us support for our
demonstrations you'd say i don't
remember that
that didn't happen
i
i'm not sure what you're saying i think
you're speculating that's hypothetical
prior to january 6 2021 you heard that
people were planning to enter the
capitol on january
6th and engage in violence right
i don't know i expect that i think
that's the fifth time
but no chance the question
no
never heard that from anybody
no
yeah
and prior to january 6 2021 you were
aware that people were gonna
make noise outside the capitol as a
means to disrupt the proceedings inside
the capitol is that fair no i have no
idea what you're talking about okay
and prior to january 6 2021 have you
heard that people were planning to enter
the capitol building illegally in order
to disrupt the electoral count process
no absolutely not i don't know anything
about that
okay
your honor it's uh i think 12 45 is well
let's talk about that um how much longer
do you think
hours you know
probably an hour all right well why
don't we take an i'm going to change
let's take an hour and let's be back
here at
12 45 so that's 145 right
right
could i respectfully ask for to make it
45 minutes only 45 minutes listen you
want to make it 12 30
i mean 1 31 30 i'm challenged on the
clock 1 30 45 minutes uh for you mr box
that's that okay with team coverage
in 45 minutes which will be one third
thank you sir
what a vile vile woman um all right i
can't thank everybody enough for being
here that does it we'll see everybody
later no there's going to be more of
this and this is one of the most
disgusting members of congress at this
time
and it's so great to have so many of you
here we are minutes from entering our
fifth hour there is matt gates acting
almost like he's providing security matt
gates is a disgusting young man and he
is in the middle of his own
investigation for child sex trafficking
across state lines he's got a hell of a
problem on his hands so does she and we
are going to continue here
um
i i do want to ask you guys a favor
i would love for you guys to support the
work we do we're mostly funded by
viewers through the membership program
just grab a membership at joinpakman.com
this is super super easy you go to
joinpakman.com we have coupon codes one
of them is obama
if you use that code
look at what the price becomes and if
you do it monthly it's wild
so i would love to have your support we
will continue streaming this all day we
don't want to miss a second of it even
when the video freezes like this
we have backup streams for you so we
have all of it we're not going to miss a
moment of it we will even refresh this
potentially
thank you to everybody who's been
supporting
well
via twitch prime as well including meech
mark kris and all these other people
uh thank you to kelly mcgowan kelly
mcgowan just signed up on my website
with the coupon code obama
i also want to say thank you to terry
schwerin george bradford
and jody bundrick who between the three
of them have gifted four subscriptions
you can also gift subscriptions on my
website those four subscriptions go to
the following people who have asked for
them
uh oh boy
they are julian ganest
kevin batdorff
judah diaz
and gary hayes
if you want a free membership just go to
davidpakman.com
free membership and you will get a put
on the list there are currently
643 people
waiting for free memberships so
hopefully we will get some of those
going also thanks to kelly dot
who um is new member number 43 today
uh people asking where the obama thing
comes from always glad to indulge us on
that ted doesn't win your second
amendment's gonna be in trouble big
trouble remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama there it is obama those are the
oranges the oranges of obama for anybody
who is
wondering
whoa memberships are dumping in thanks
to brandon thames
and thomas connell numbers 44 and 45
a david dinar
is gifting a membership that's number 46
and the lucky recipient is mark riley
mark congratulations
oh some generous people here
tyler mcclure has just signed up in his
new member number 47 at joinedpakman.com
actual one is number 48.
it's hard to even keep up with what's
happening here and the super chats are
flying in i think we need to elect
people with better memories i agree
i pay monthly without a code for a
reason thanks pair pair foregoing the
coupon code robert mcshane is new member
number 49. hey you know what
number 50 i'll send you a free item from
my online store
coffee mug hat hoodie whatever whoever
is next number 50 at 49 number 50 at
joinpackman.com
even if you use a coupon code i will
indeed uh send you a free item we do
have people calling in
about what's going on here
david dustin
from a suburb near tulsa oklahoma are
you going to reveal your list of sex on
the world famous boner show
my list of sex i don't even know what
that means that's bizarre
that's bizarre
other um let's see other comments about
the hearing so far
um let's see if there's anything else
here
hello david sir
um i want to talk about massive dumps no
oh my god i don't really um i just some
of my republican friends have been
um
posting and talking about
a data dump okay now
we can't do the data dump stuff today we
just we just can't do that that it's not
the day for it we have something that's
too too uh big going on to talk about
the data dumps that's gonna have to be
on a different day
thank you to skittlestuh who has just
gifted two subs on twitch and frank
morningtree a third
uh that's really very much appreciated
but number 50 kind of with the free item
is scott woodard scott has just signed
up on my website with the coupon code
obama
you're number 50 even though you're kind
of 53 please email in scott and we'll
send you an item uh also thanks to
laurie miller and natalie saltzman
stephen donato and kimberly koehler
mark grobner and jason gartner
helga har
elizabeth bornman
brook colburn daniel davis
and sebastian araya who have all signed
up that puts us at 62
and then gifts are coming in as well oh
god i think the website's about to crash
from the membership pressure
uh wait nancy coughlin and andy levy and
sean empson have just signed up that's
65.
god i hope the website doesn't crash uh
we just received a gift from david dinar
which is number 66. that gift goes to
trevor welsh yes guys if you want a free
membership it's
membership
uh oh i don't know if we can hold her
the website is
very very under stress
thanks to zach thomas and suzanne hopp
numbers 67 and 68
jamie o'toole is new member number 69
also thanks to terry white
and scott thatcher
number 70 and 71
also a gift coming in from adam gingrich
adam is one of the top gifters that gift
goes to robert grant congratulations
robert
cole has gifted a membership that's
number 73 and that one goes to john
harshbarger
and then i want to say thanks to
charlotte stone
joelle snyder and jojo doyle putting us
at 76. did i miss anybody
oh
is number 77
uh okay and then darla vaughan
adrian haagen and ryan meager put us at
um oh my god there's 41 people trying to
sign up right now i don't even know if
the website can hold this to be
perfectly frank
super chat's coming in
the judge seems corrupt
that that's a big claim uh i don't are
we ready to speak about the judge's
corruption i don't know about that
um
hold on did the website crash
no the website's still up the website's
still up
all right everybody i'm gonna take lunch
i'm gonna make a turkey sandwich and
then we will all be back here at the
bottom of the hour the stream continues
everybody stand by
our presentation on the law from mr bob
we did not object to that
i will let you answer the question i
forgot what it is
can we ask for it to be right back
question
if you were
aware that somebody was going to
unlawfully interfere with the
constitutional process of counting
electoral votes you would be obliged
to have them arrested or stopped right
you may answer
you may answer the question to the best
of your bill
i had no knowledge
of any attempt and so that's a question
that i can't answer well
i can't answer that question i i i take
your representation that you had no
knowledge for the for the time being i'm
asking it as a hypothetical question
just to understand
your answer a hypothetical question well
i'm permitted to ask you one so i'm
going to ask you again if you had
knowledge in advance that someone was
going to unlawfully interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes in a
presidential election
under your oath you'd be obliged to do
something to stop that
not being charged for violating her hope
there's no pro foundation laid that she
had any knowledge about anything like
that we'll come to that and so these
hypotheticals
let me try it a different way on the
screen
remember the part in the oath where you
talked about
taking on the obligations of the oath
freely and without mental reservation or
purpose of evasion you recall that from
a few minutes ago right
yes okay
if you knew
that
people were planning to interfere
with the constitutional process of
counting the electoral votes
you knew that before you took the oath
and you took the oath anyway
and decided not to do anything
about those plans
that would be a mental reservation don't
you agree object she's not she is not
being charged with violating the elders
the question is does she engage in
insurrection or rebellion
her state of mind is relevant your honor
we think it's very important to have her
understanding what
it's relevant to whether she engaged in
insurrection during the time period from
january 3rd to january 6th and we're
going to be talking about her state of
mind all day you may come back to that
question after you have laid a
foundation for why it ties into her her
activities mom and after the fair enough
fair enough drama
um ms green you're familiar with social
media right
and that's a form of communication right
yes you know what facebook is and
twitter right yes you use those as an
important form of communication in your
work
yes you post messages on facebook right
i post statements messages yes videos
also right
yeah
and you also
respond and react to other people's
comments when they're posted on facebook
or twitter right
yes
and you do that
as a way to get your political views out
into the world
it's my freedom of speech to do so i
agree
and you've been very successful at using
social media to get your your views out
of the world right
i would say that's an opinion well i'm
asking your opinion you've got hundreds
of thousands of people
who follow you
on twitter and facebook right
no not really because my twitter my
personal twitter account
doesn't exist anymore before it was
suspended by twitter
you had hundreds of thousands of people
following you on facebook and twitter
right yeah and by the way
the way facebook and twitter work is my
understanding is they don't have to
necessarily follow you to read what you
have to say right
i guess so so
it could be millions of people who have
read the things that you have said on
facebook and twitter over the years
i don't know that
but it could be you would agree with
that right no i don't know that okay i
don't know how many people read or see
what i post on social media
but what you post on social media is
what you want people to know about your
political beliefs
correct
um
sure okay you're not putting stuff up
there as a joke are you
sometimes yes
um well we'll go we'll come back to that
um
and you use facebook and twitter to
to communicate with your constituents in
the 14th congressional district here in
georgia right yes
so
immediately after the 2020 election
and through january 6th and even beyond
that
um you issued a number of
tweets and made statements on twitter
and facebook about the election right
yes he tweeted a whole lot of material
about your views of what happened in the
2020 election yes and
the thrust of those tweets
were that you felt that the election was
stolen from the sitting president i
object that that is uh
you can ask the question what is your
opinion what is it well well i also want
to ask whether she communicated that
opinion through
well let's do it that way your honor i i
take your point
where are you going with this council
i'm going to show the witness a number
of her tweets and i wanted to make sure
that i understand the context of them
that's all
well she said she posts on twitter right
and my question is whether she posts
material that reflect the opinion that
you have strike that ms green you you
have you had the opinion between
november
2020 when the election happened on
january 6
2021 that the election was stolen from
president trump i objected to am i right
about that
if you've got questions about specific
documents or specific things go ahead
let's not uh
let's let's go to px2a as well as please
i'm sorry which one is this
a 2a your honor
can you see that on the screen
and
what we have here in in 2a is a document
um
well i'll ask you um can you tell us
is this a statement that you posted
on twitter
uh
on december 3rd 2020
i'll go ahead and go here sure
i'm sorry
yes ma'am
yes yeah and
this is a
statement where you talk about
um that you were looking for a senator
to join yourself and representative mo
brooks to reject the fraudulent votes
for joe biden and to keep the real
donald trump in the white house right i
exact uh your honor to
the
you can hear my objection i'm waiting
i'm waiting with bated breath jim all
right
uh it is
this violates a right of free speech
there's nothing in this statement
that meets the brand of her test even if
speech could be considered
since it can't
when we're dealing with
engages which is conduct not speak and
uh and it does not provide does not even
meet the incitement as
uh which requires directed to inciting
or producing imminent lawless action
your honor we heard an hour of argument
this morning oh hold on hold on
so thank you honor that is likely to
incite or produce a action in the quote
so it's objectionable and and to call
her into account for her first amendment
free speech is unconstitutional
i appreciate your argument but that's
argument i'm going to allow the question
go ahead mr
when you sent out this
strike that did you send out this tweet
it was green
as well could you put it back up
yes okay
and when you sent out this tweet you
wanted the people who read the tweet to
know that it was your view
that
the votes for mr biden for president
were fraudulent or some of them were
right
that really wasn't the purpose of that
tweet
i'm just asking whether when you sent
this you were communicating to your the
people who read your twitter account
that you believed
that there were fraudulent votes for mr
biden
and that your goal was to keep president
trump in the white house
i was communicating that we were looking
for a senator to join our objection
which is very much
part of the
responsibilities and duties
that i can do as a member of congress i
agree with that
but the purpose of that
was because you believed
that the votes for mr biden were
fraudulent right or at least some of
them
we had we had been
spending a vast amount of time reading
and researching and talking to people
and have seen uh tremendous evidence of
voter fraud i don't know if you're aware
because i know you're not from georgia
we currently have our secretary of state
your honor i would move to strike this
i'm entitled to get answers to my
questions your honor
thank you thank you
all right let's let's back up
by the way your honor i'm sorry to
interrupt we missed something very
important can the representative be
sworn
oh thank you no i swore oh you did oh
okay i didn't see that i'm sorry
i'm sorry thank you all right
um
and can i ask the court to acknowledge
that this is a an adverse wisdom witness
and
i would ask the court to remind the
witness that in this posture she has to
answer my questions she can't give
speeches
is that fair she's entitled you're
entitled to an answer to the question
that is asked she's not entitled to know
your answer you're not entitled to
answers that are
uh
to require her to answer when the
question is objectionable violates the
first amendment rights is irrelevant to
the charges that are
uh being made
just to
what phishing expedition political
theater what is this this is this is
cross-examination
i'm entitled to a yes no or i can't
answer responses let's go ahead and
unless this isn't objectionable
you have a standing objection mr bob
to everything in the world i want to
question your witness let her catch you
know
she's doing fine wait a minute
that's another stop let's probably sit
down next question
this is not theater
this is not an argument from the supreme
court this is an evidentiary hearing so
let's get going go ahead mr shelley
um ms wells can you pull up plaintiff's
exhibit
2c please
the screen
is this a
tweet
that you sent out from your account
on december 19
2020
yes
and in this tweet um
let me go back a second your honor i
would just ask that
the previous exhibit which i think was
2d be um admitted into evidence
2d
i'm sorry 2a all right so 2a is b
um and i'd ask that 2c be admitted into
evidence
to see
all right
say that again i was distracted go
through it again sure i asked the
witness if this was her tweet she said
it was this is your tweet okay and i ask
it if he admitted into evidence i object
that it's not probative and it violates
her first amendment right well it has
nothing to do with engage it doesn't uh
january it's in for what it's worth mr
bob okay i mean i don't mean it's worth
anything but it's in
thank you um representative green um in
your tweet on
december 19th 2020 that we've marked as
plaintiff's exhibit 2c
one of the things you're communicating
to the people who would read this tweet
was that you want them to come to
washington
on january 6th
for a demonstration
is that right
for a march for trump right march for
fight for trump
the phrase that you use there
is hashtag fight for trump right that's
what the words say that's what it says
on my tweet okay
um
and you posted that because you in fact
wanted people to show up
on january 6
2021 in dc
in order to help you
stop
the theft of the 2020 election from your
point of view
now
okay
well i'm not sure we got a clear answer
on this you you did believe at this time
that the 2020 election had been stolen
by the democrats from mr trump
right i i was asking people to come for
a peaceful march which is
what everyone
is entitled to do
under their first amendment but i was
not asking them to actively engage in
violence or any type of action
my question is really simple it's about
your opinion
when this tweet came out in this period
it was your opinion that the election
had been stolen from mr trump or was
about to be stolen right
under my opinion there was a tremendous
amount of
fraudulent
things that happened in the election
and under my opinion i want to do
anything i can to protect election
integrity and to protect
the
the people of my district in georgia
uh people's votes they should count
is it fair to say
representative greene that from election
night of 2020
until january 6 2021
your personal opinion and your wish
was that congress not certify
joe biden as the winner of the 2020
election
uh no that's not accurate
uh you you believed that joe biden had
lost the election to mr trump right
well yes we saw a tremendous amount of
voter fraud we have uh investigations
going on right now in the state of
georgia there's investigations going on
in multiple states
my own husband showed up to vote on the
general election and when he went in to
vote in person he was told that he had
already voted by absentee ballot when in
fact he had never even requested an
absentee ballot but there's many
instances
and that a portion of testimony from
georgia republican representative
marjorie taylor-green in a hearing to
determine whether she should be allowed
to run for re-election to congress a
group opposing her candidacy is citing a
provision of the 14th amendment to the
constitution that states that if a
member of congress takes part in an
insurrection or rebellion against the
federal government they're disqualified
for running for re-election she's been
associated with the january 6th attack
on the u.s capitol
hearing expected to resume in about 15
minutes or so and of course our live
coverage will continue here on c-span
while we wait here is more of her
testimony from a short time ago
service of green i think we're ready
come on back
right up everybody ready we're good god
we're back on the record
we appreciate your patience with the
disruption appreciate everybody's
cooperation while they're dealt with
technology that's one of the mains of
human existence
all right
i would just ask that mr bob not consult
with his client in the break period
while i'm examining her that's generally
not permitted
in my experience
go ahead
can you see uh plaintiff's exhibit two
seed pleased as well
i'm sorry we want to see
okay um
in the screen this is a tweet that we
talked about a little bit earlier just a
quick question on it
you issued this on
december 19 2020 correct
i can't see real well but i think that's
the day maybe maybe we can make it a
little larger
that's what it says
and
what you were doing in this
tweet was you were
tweeting out a story
from the epic times
about president trump saying that the
protests that were planned for january 6
were going to be quote wild right not
object we don't have the
where's the article right there under
the picture under the picture of
president trump there's a quote that yes
it says trump trump call in supporters
should join wild protest in dc on john
cena okay i would draw my objection i
can't see that i can't make it a little
larger as well it doesn't say that
okay
you can answer the question
representative green what was your
question my question is what you were
doing in the street is you were tweeting
out a story
from the epic times
about president trump making a statement
that the protest on january 6th
would be wild
right
i tweeted an article that had the
details of the dates and times right and
also included president trump's
statements that he expected the
demonstrations on january 6 to be wild
right
i don't think that's what my tweet was
about okay well but you see that the
article says trump colon supporters
should join quote wild protests in dc
on jazz
i don't remember tweeting that
specifically for what you're saying
those are your words
no those aren't mine i'm actually
reading from what's on the you're
speculating on why i tweeted that but i
don't remember tweeting it for that
specific reason is green i'm just asking
questions i'm just answering
and
in your tweet you mentioned earlier that
um
your words join the hashtag march for
trump and dc on january 6 to fight for
trump that you were urging people to
come to washington for a peaceful
demonstration right
peaceful demonstration absolutely yeah
that word peaceful is nowhere in the
street right
that word peaceful i can't read it
there's only half of it there let's
let's get give the representative a
paper copy of that one
no i can see it now it was scrolled up
just a second ago okay peaceful it's not
in there is it
um
well you know like is the word peaceful
in there miss green it does not say
peaceful right
but you're asking me and i said for
peaceful
demonstration
just like people have the right to do in
their first amendment i'm asking
you there's not a secret code in there
that's supposed to be peaceful right
well i never mean anything for violence
i don't support violence of any kind and
i've said it over and over again
so i i'm telling you you just didn't say
it on this occasion did you i never mean
anything for violence
all of my words never ever mean anything
for violence we'll we'll examine that
question go to uh plans to do the two
out please
and i'm looking at the
um yes this top half of the exhibit
mrs green this is a tweet that you sent
out
uh on january 2nd 2021 correct
i'm not sure
okay you don't recall this
i i don't recall tweeting that now okay
you can set that to one side
well let me ask this question
does anybody
tweet things on your twitter account
strike that did anybody in january of
2021 tweet things on your twitter
account without your permission
on what day
anytime from
november of 2020 to january 6th
i don't remember that's difficult to
answer okay would you you'd be surprised
if somebody got into your twitter
account and tweeted something without
your permission wouldn't you
well no one tweeted anything without my
permission i just don't remember
who tweeted what fair enough
now
would you agree in this screen that
this tweet
from january 2nd 2021
is something that we can fairly
attribute to you being that it was
tweeted on your twitter account
i
i'm sorry i
i don't know
okay
um
ms green you've had your disagreements
with speaker pelosi isn't that right
i'm not sure what you mean you've had
political disagreements with her you
don't agree with some of the things
she's done in her career right
politically speaking that would be
correct you don't agree with a lot of
things she's done right
politically speaking that would be
correct in fact you think that speaker
pelosi is a traitor to the country right
uh you're i'm not answering that
question of speculation and
hypothetically you said that haven't you
ms green that she's a traitor to the
country no i haven't said that okay
but
oh no wait
hold on now i believe
by not upholding the uh securing the
border
that that violates
her oath of office
fair enough i'm i'm not interested in
narrative office i'm interested in that
you said
that she's a traitor to our country
right i have objections she is uh this
is
i don't see the relevance of that mr
chilly next your honor can we give mr
gop a standing objection on the first
amendment grounds
this is this is this is an effort to
interrupt my
examination of the witness
they're not live yet right this is still
from earlier
the witnesses
desire
to engage in insurrection
during the period january 3rd to january
6. that's true
so we'll chat all right welcome
everybody i am back from uh from lunch
it's a great great thing
uncharged piccolo let's take a break
lunch is here the food is here all right
so we are waiting for them to return
and um what was on my sandwich it was a
turkey sandwich turkey cheddar
on extremely sour sourdough
with mayonnaise
what else did i put on it actually wait
a second no i had um i think i actually
had a calzone by the way how are the
calzones no um
pickle
wouldn't i have pickle
bell pepper
um
and sliced olives and uh spinach as well
and i had an apple if you can believe it
or not on the sandwich of course not
yeah just okay good
all right
the judge seems corrupt still our latest
super chat okay good let me uh so so
many questions
when does this resume in five minutes
what is happening next marjorie taylor
green still being questioned by the by
the petitioners for about an additional
hour
is she then going to be questioned by
her own counsel i genuinely don't know
um
what other witnesses are we going to
hear from i don't know
how many days is this going to go we
don't know
um
i think in theory it was going to be one
day
uh oh sorry this is cross-examination
right yeah so so
it's these were these are the
petitioners what i'm saying is i don't
know if her defense counsel will get to
question her or how that uh how that's
going to work
um there will be many objections exactly
let's get caught up on anybody
who has supported us since i walked away
and that is erroneous
slingblade
stuck a duck
tobias
pathord
sobi
via twitch prime putting us at
86
and then i do need to try to get caught
up oh my god the number i don't even
know if i can do all the gifts that came
in
let's try okay the following people are
sending gifts in a moment i'll tell you
who's getting them this is on my website
joinpakman.com
david dinar
whoops not this one
tamisha faulkner
oh i wonder if that's tamesha from the
bronx who calls in i think it might be
uh so tamisha
let me see here
jennifer devoe
kelly cisco
um
and tiffany mclay so that puts us at 91
the lucky recipients are
micah morgan
reuben sanchez benjamin costello d gold
and ann keeley so those are gifts all
right
then i want to thank the people who just
signed up for themselves
uh oh sorry hold on i i'm trying to keep
up with it all rick chadwell also sends
a gift that's number 92 and the
recipient there is jim gatz if you want
a free membership go to davidpakman.com
free membership there's currently
661 people waiting
now here are the people
um
self-centered individuals getting
themselves memberships no i'm kidding
brenda spicer
andy levy
brian rodman
garrett hoyer
billy diesen
tim frost
mary brennaman is number seven
uh nancy wilson is number eight
christian martin nine adrian wells ten
john lovett here eleven theodore hartman
is number twelve
drizzle bannis
is number thirteen
k buchanan is fourteen john pam's 15
michelle kozenska
16 virginia drapkin is 17.
michael wu is 18. that puts us at 110
which is already off the charts
and then samuel baker
laurie morgan i'm determined to thank
everybody dorothy green
pamela palumbo pamela pamela what am i
talking about pamela that wow that
sounds really stupid i said it like
pomelo pamela
uh thanks pamela no pamela we got a gift
from drizzle bannis which is number 115
that gift goes to denise london
um
sandy hill signed up
michael sacks
and i think that that puts me where we
need to be at 117
did i get everybody i think i did
and over on bezos bucks jen here jerk
face wagner filthy fim
using their bezos bucks
on twitch putting us at 121.
remember if you have amazon prime you
get a free
twitch prime subscription beautiful
thing
super chats
thanks for your fantastic work you're my
go-to for well thought out commentary
says ace of spade thank you
secret squirrel sends a super chat oh
where was i interviewed earlier so when
i stepped away earlier i was interviewed
on this british channel called
trigonometry i guess it's like right
wing although i don't really know
anything about it and we did have some
disagreements we spoke for about 45
minutes i don't know when they're
publishing it but
i think you're going to find it
interesting it was a two-on-one i was
defending myself against brutal attacks
from two
they seemed like center-right i guess
is anybody familiar with
trigonometry they're british exactly
yes
thanks to hat mumfree and web tech for
the twitch prime subscriptions very much
appreciate that the subject matter so
here's so i tried to make it mostly
about like economics and stuff like that
but they kept wanting to ask me about
like cultural issues and i was like guys
i don't this is these are not real
issues you know
uh these are issues that the right uses
because they've abandoned policy and we
did talk about we talked about trans we
talked about immigration and all these
different things
i think it will be interesting when they
publish it
did i put spicy mustard you know
normally i do put mustard on my turkey
sandwich but today i did not i went with
usually i'll take
mayo on one bread element and mustard on
the other
sometimes i'll use a grain mustard
sometimes dijon
yellow probably not today i went mayo on
both sides which is unusual but just
because of the seriousness of the event
i'm covering it felt as though mustard
use would be uncouth
call me crazy but
that's my view
i want to say thanks to eric ubelman who
is new member number 124 i have two more
gifts david is the best sends a gift and
haley from georgia sends a gift
the recipients are mark smann
and kyle eldridge thank you so much a
lot of people are like who is this guy
in the lower right hand corner of my
screen i was just looking for the
testimony we're all asking that question
this is the david pakman show youtube
channel
um and i would love for you to stick
around and we're about to get started
here
i do want to ask you one favor though i
need 11 000 votes give me a break it's
nothing like that no no no it's just if
you've been enjoying the stream
sign up at joinpackman.com now what is
this comment well hold on
uh
i'm not sure sandwiches are the best
thing for david to be eating what the
hell does that mean
what does that even mean
anyway yeah you can get yourself a
membership at joinpakman.com it's
primarily how we how we do what we do
it's our number one funding source and
if you have a membership you can check
this box right here
which is is this a gift
and that will basically put your
membership in a queue to be given to
someone who is waiting for a membership
there are currently
659 people
waiting for memberships so we'll see if
we can give away
some of those
i need 11 000 memberships give me a
break
okay voicemails yep we've got a couple
of um
couple voicemails i think related to the
hearings
hey dude uh just wondering are you
much of a dessert person and if you are
are you more like a pastries
and a person or more like ice cream or
maybe even potentially candy no candy
not huge on ice cream
um for me the top desserts are flan
chocolate bobcat tiramisu
pistachio baklava
for me it's it's hard to do better than
those for uh those four desserts
she don't know on everything yep
i'm telling you she gonna say no on
everything
oh i don't know i forgot
i don't know okay
now that voicemail is from 20 minutes
ago so it's not that much of a
prediction because we already saw like
hours of that
but it's a fair point and that is
exactly what is going on
david
mtg is
getting on my nerve
her little smug little look on the
podium i know and
oh and she keeps
i don't recall
no i don't i don't know i don't recall
uh i don't think so yeah well what i'm
curious about is oh the judge is back
what i'm curious about is whether the
lawyers will find a way around i don't
recall let's find out
[Music]
she's back
thank you
okay
mr kelly
then we'll move to another topic um
the twitter handle at mt green
that's your twitter twitter handle right
or it was before your account was
suspended
before my account was permanently banned
got it
and during the period from january 3rd
to january 6
did you or anybody in your office
your congressional office
provide tours either formally or
informally
the people of the u.s capitol
no the only people that were with me was
my husband and my children
that would be on the third is that right
they were i don't recall the exact days
i believe they went back to georgia on
the fourth okay i'm trying to capture
the period
in january third when you were sworn in
on january 6th
anytime during that period
did anybody in your office provide tours
to anybody from the us
no okay
and during that period
did anybody
on your campaign staff
or did you authorize a provision of
funds and money
to people who were planning a
demonstration on january 6
i don't think so i don't recall that at
all
if you wanted to know the answer to that
question who would you ask
um
i would have to talk to
people in my campaign but
i don't think we did anything how would
we have done that we didn't do anything
like that
during that same period of january 3rd
to january 6
did you or anybody on your campaign or
congressional staff
provide any information of any sort
to anyone in connection with
january 6 demonstrations
i don't think so
i have no idea i don't think so
and
did you know members of the public visit
your congressional office between
january 3rd and january 6th no
and during that period from january 3rd
to january 6
did anyone from your congressional
office or your campaign
provide
maps for the the location of offices
within the capitol
no no we got our keys to my office on
january 3rd i i couldn't even find where
the bathroom was most of the time
you know why i'm asking these questions
don't you representative green i have no
idea why you're asking these questions
representative green
you're familiar with the
significance of the year 1776
in u.s history right
yes
1776 is the year that the declaration of
independence was signed right
and that was a statement
by representatives of the 13 colonies
that they were no longer subject to the
authority of the british crown right
they were declared it was the
declaration of independence from the
british crown right and in fact you may
recall this from your studies the
declaration of uh independence refers to
king george's titus right
i'm sure it may say that somewhere in
the history books i don't have the
history books in front of me and i don't
know which one you're referring to but
well i'm referring to the declaration of
independence that's the one that says
that king george was a tyrant unfit to
be a ruler of a free deal are you
quoting the declaration okay
well you'll accept that for me
if you're quoting it okay
and you would agree that
when a government
acts tyrannically
then it's unfit to be the ruler of the
free people
we're typically against tyrannical
governments here
and the people who
wrote the declaration of independence
they were working with other people in
the colonies
to express their independence from
britain right
i wasn't alive back then but there's the
history i'm not i'm not a history expert
but we know as you've heard of the
american revolution haven't you of
course i have yes and you know that the
american revolution
was a violent rebellion
against british rule in the colonies
yes
and
they were trying to overthrow the
government
in britain that was ruling the colonies
right
uh america was trying to start our own
government
right and to do that you didn't know
the british colonial officials who were
here in america and throw them out
they yes
and they viewed
the british officials here and the crown
in britain as a tyrannical government
right okay
that was an insurrection wouldn't you
agree
the american revolution was an
insurrection against the government i
don't believe it i don't know where it
said that
well i'm asking you whether or not you
agree
that the american revolution was an
insurrection against the british
government i believe it was the american
revolution was is part of our history
where we
separated from
from the crown
and started our own government here
right and the separation was brought
about by violence right there was a
revolutionary war yes
and the violence of the
the colonists were justified in using
violence
to get rid of the tyrannical government
of britain their officials in in america
right
is that your
opinion assume so
it was a revolutionary war it was
violent okay
now
you've actually talked publicly about
the declaration of independence calling
for the overthrow of tyrannical
governments right that's something
you've discussed
are you referencing to something i've
said somewhere well do you recall
talking about that topic i've talked
about the declaration of independence
but i don't know what occasion you're
referring to in a penance
of course
well one of the occasions
where you talked about the declaration
of independence
was in connection with january 6th right
i don't know okay let's go to um
plaintiff
15 please
could get interesting
it goes from knowing a lot to knowing
nothing very quickly which one is just
which one is this one
15 p15 type yes
on real america's voice this looks like
bannon's program
ms green i'm gonna play a short clip and
ask if that's you
speaking on the on the video okay what
what's the date on this i can't read it
october 26 2021
it's a riot at the capitol and if you
think about what our declaration of
independence says it says to overthrow
tyrants
that's your statement right
i don't believe it was finished but that
was me i don't i don't recall i don't
know what the rest of what i was saying
because it was cut off
but in that statement that we looked at
you're comparing
the overthrow of the british crown in
america in 1776
to january 6. i don't know what my
statement was because it was cut off
liar
now you talked about the need for people
to have guns
in order to secure
their rights against the tyrannical
government right
that's
yes we have a second amendment for a
good reason right and the good reason is
in case they need to overthrow their
government they can use their guns to do
that
we we have us well
you're you're twisting things around
could you rephrase your question
well i'm i'm reacting to your answer you
said we have second amendment i'm not
just going to bail her out and i said
that the reason from your point of view
that there is a second amendment is so
that people can overthrow their
government by violent means with guns
that's not the exact purpose we defend
ourselves um say if you know
if you're being attacked um you know a
gun is a tool to defend yourself right
and
but one of the things that could be used
for let's write that let's let's go to
um
px6
that's matt gates in the gray suit guys
by the way with the huge head
like i should talk about huge heads by
the way i'm just pointing it out i'm
going to play a video here and ask a
couple questions about it
well first let me just ask you do you
recall
giving an interview
as reflected on
px6
in october of 2020 just about a week
before the election
uh at something called the relic hunter
firearms shop
i vaguely remember okay and that's you
on the left and the gentleman on the
right is the owner of the shop am i
right about that
no okay who who's that just right now uh
mr dore
who's mr door
he's uh he's a gun rights
jimmy dore he's a gun right just someone
i know got it and
it's backwards because of the video but
it's remembering a lot suddenly it says
um
let's say
i am 177
sure
that no one is taking my guns
do you agree that that's what it says
yes okay
um so explain the video i object to
playing this i object watch this
right in the middle
there is a section cut off
right in the middle well let's see so it
has been edited
and who's the source
uncharted piccolo's source of this is
marjorie taylor green it's earned with
the price of blood that's that's what
we're gonna be talking about no who's
the source of the video who where did we
get this one what's the name of the
videographer
well i you know i know you'll need to
see it but we'll see it and you can make
it obviously that
it's difficult to cross-examine the
video but it's certainly possible to say
what's different i'm going to ask a lot
of questions about it judgment she can
tell us if it's yeah you can have it as
best she can you know
go
ahead but let me stop we're not watching
the whole thing we're picking up in the
middle of it is that correct it's uh a
minute and nine seconds yarn
i don't know what i'm asking is
it right oh i see it says sure i look
like we were halfway into the video
that's why i was i was good we started
the beginning yeah i'm playing the whole
thing
just to the very beginning yeah let's
start it over again please object
so let's start this is a tv your honor
yeah
but here's the deal if this generation
doesn't stand up and defend freedom it's
gone
and once it's gone freedom doesn't come
back by itself
the only way you get your freedoms back
is that it's earned with the price of
blood we can't be too busy or too
complacent or too worried about
offending someone anymore it's there's
no more excuses this is this is it
november 3rd freedom is on the ballot
you have a choice of either voting for
freedom by voting for donald j trump for
president again for four years voting
republicans straight down your ballot or
you're going to vote for socialism and
vote to completely
end america as we know it and this is
this is no joke they do not want you to
be able to defend yourself because if
you can defend yourself guess what then
you can stop a tyrannical government
however if they take away your gun then
you can't not only can you never stop a
tyrannical government you can never even
defend yourself if someone is breaking
in your home and and that's the reality
this is where we are today in 2020
oh okay [ __ ]
let me uh
it started off with
a cut sentence when she said but that's
clearly it okay so whatever she said
before is wiped out and then you saw
three times
when it was cut
yeah okay yeah and
mother jones i'm sorry i am not going to
rely upon that it's so absurd because
it's like it's obviously her words
we can proceed with questioning the
witness can respond i mean it is the
witness in his statement she made
and she can respond so go ahead let's
let's establish that
representative green this is a statement
that you made in an interview with mr
dore in october of 2020. that is a very
partial cut off and pasted statement
speaking but my sentences are cut off my
full message is not there okay
and in that statement
what you say is if you can defend
yourself you can stop a tyrannical
government
however if they take away your guns
you can never stop the tyrannical
government right correct okay and you
believe that
absolutely
and in fact
what was done in 1776 was to stop a
tyrannical government with guns
there
sure yeah and and that was to use
violence against a tyrannical government
to get that clear
you know they were they were trying to
get rid of a tyrannical government they
were there was more violent i mean there
was a big process there was a big build
up there before the revolutionary war
the whole purpose was not to use guns
look at the judge
is the narrative look at the judge
trying to push here what did you mean
when you said that
judge rolling his eyes once you lose
your freedom it has to be earned with
the price of blood
well once i've always said i'm against
violence and i've always said i never
want to see a war in this country
never i've said that over and over again
in many speeches
and the reason why i say that is because
i don't want to see war here on american
soil
i have three children that are young
adults and i never want to see my
children fighting a war earning back our
freedoms and i've said that that's what
i'm talking about it wasn't actually
earned with the price of blood is a
reference to violence isn't it
the price of blood is the unfortunate
and tragic cost of war
and that's what happened in the
revolutionary war and and that's what
i'm talking about
and you know that
um
the term 1776
is actually a term that's sometimes used
in politics today
i don't know if you've noticed our state
seal here in georgia i know you're not
from georgia but as you can see we we
enjoy our history and we're proud of our
freedoms 1776 is on our state seal right
and it's also a term that's used in
political discourse in america today
i don't use it as a term of violence
but you use it as a term right
i have used it as a term but i do not
use it as a term of violence
as you're trying to push we're not we're
not up to that yet you'll have your
chances and there's some question you
want to answer but you have to start by
answering my question okay sure
um
you acknowledge that 1776 is a term
that's used in political discourse today
right
yes and
in fact one of the examples of 1776
being used in political discourse today
is the t-shirt that mr door was hearing
in the interview that we just saw right
we saw 1776 backwards on his t-shirt on
that cut up video right yes
and you understood that t-shirt to me
that people need to possess firearms in
order to oppose a tyrannical government
i don't recall
even
i don't remember seeing his t-shirt that
day when he doesn't recall remembering
the only time i'm paying attention to it
is now because you're drawing the
reference but as you sit here today you
understand that what that t-shirt is
conveying it's a political message
is that people needed to need to possess
firearms in order to oppose a tyrannical
government
i don't necessarily
understand what you're trying to say i'm
just asking whether you have that
understanding or not
i think you're more trying to push a
narrative and push words in my mouth and
i don't agree with what you're saying
necessarily
as you sit here today representative
green
you you know that that term 1776
has been used in connection with the
events of january 6 2001.
um
i guess it i guess so i don't know well
you yourself have used the term 1776
to describe
the events of january 6
2021.
i don't recall but if you say
let's go to um px27 please
let's see if this will jog your memory
mark
by the way this video
your honor has been admitted into
evidence right
um
ms wells
uh no it wasn't actually planned uh but
president trump knows how much i support
him he knows how much i support our
district uh georgia's 14th district
and so i was happy to go up there and
encourage our voters to get out and vote
we can't allow our two democ our two
republican senators lose their seats to
two radical socialist democrats so i was
excited to get up there and also
cheer on senator kelly lefler for
announcing last night that she'll be
objecting to this fraudulent stolen
election tomorrow on january 6 and i'm
very excited that uh both of us women
representing georgians will be fighting
for president trump and fighting for the
integrity of our elections tomorrow what
is your plan tomorrow how do you plan to
handle what could possibly go down uh in
this joint session of congress tomorrow
um are what are you prepared for
well you know i'll echo the words of uh
many of my colleagues as we were just
meeting together in our gop conference
meeting this morning this is our
1776 moment whoa
um
that's your statement on january 5th
2021 correct
i don't know the date i i again i don't
recall but now that i've seen it what
what was the date of the video
january 5th 2021. i'm going to take my
word for it we can play it back and
you'll see that you're talking about
that tomorrow is the sixth okay yes okay
well now you acknowledge uh this is two
days after you took the oath of office
to be a representative from the 14th
congressional district right
yes and you used the term 1776
to describe to in response to a question
from the newsmax broadcaster right
i was speaking about objecting
well you he asked you what is your plan
what are you prepared to have go down
tomorrow on january 6th and your
response was
tomorrow is our 1776 moment
we're talking about the courage to
object
and
you said you were echoing the words of
your republican colleagues
was the term 1776 used by your
republican colleagues
i don't recall
that was the video that i don't recall
right
um in fact representative bobert
has used the term 1776 to describe the
event this january 6th hasn't changed
i don't recall i have no idea let's go
to px9e please
and px nine nine nine e nine e thank you
this is great
this woman's such a loser
um
do you recall seeing
a tweet from representative bober from
colorado
at 8 30 in the morning on january 6 2001
today is 1776.
don't remember seeing this i see it now
if that's her tweet
do you have any doubt that
representative bobert used the term 1776
to describe the events of january 6th
i don't know let's go back to px27
please
so that was an interview that you gave
to newsmax right
that's what it said on the screen
newsmax okay well you're not denying
that no i just said i don't even
remember the interview until he doesn't
know anything
and
that interview
was posted that day
on your facebook page
i don't remember
people voted for this woman if you can
imagine um
now when you said uh this is our 17th
76th moment
you knew that some of the people who
felt that donald trump was the rightful
winner of the 2020 election
used that term to refer to the
possibility of violence on january 6
2021.
no i never heard anyone talking about
violence for january 6.
absolutely not i've never heard about
anyone using the term 1776 to refer to
the fact i would never use my question
representative excuse me sorry i don't
mean to cut you off no i apologize yes
you've never heard anybody say
use the term 1776
as a code word
for violence
to occur on january 6 2021 no absolutely
not
are you you're familiar with a group
called the proud boys
i've heard of them
you know that i mean they're my friends
the proud boys
it has developed
had a written plan
for
conduct on january 6 2021 right
no i did not know that okay
the proud boys are an extremist violent
proof you would agree with that
i don't know much about the proud boys
right
never heard that they're a violent
extremist group
i've heard about them i don't know what
they do i i don't know much about the
brown boys
and you haven't heard that the
written plan
attributed to the proud boys for january
6th was called 1776 returns
no i have no idea anything about that
never heard that okay let's pull up uh
px39
i don't know where this is going but i'm
interested
he seems to need glasses or contacts too
i don't know if you guys have noticed
article that appeared uh in the new york
times on march 14 2020
uh entitled document in jan six case
shows planned to storm government
buildings
do you see this document
i've never seen it no let me let me get
you a copy so you can have a look
it's possible this goes nowhere and it's
possible that they're about the crusher
i don't know i genuinely don't know
do you know so much about antifa and
nothing about the proud boys it's weird
mrs green did you see a story
in new york times or any other
publication or media outlet
in march of 22 2022 about proud boys
having a written plan to storm
government buildings on january 6th
no
i've never i don't recall never heard
anything about it never heard of that
never heard that that was called 1776
returns that planned as the government
alleges
proud boys had to storm government
buildings
no i've never heard of it
you were aware of prior to january 6
that 1776
referred to an idea or a plan
for people who were opposed to the
certification of the electoral college
vote
to infiltrate and occupy
buildings in d.c
no never
no
and you were aware prior to january 6
2021 that 1776 was a term that people
were using to describe a plan or an idea
to physically interfere and prevent the
electoral college though
no i don't know anything about that okay
you can put that to one side we um
talk a little bit about a person named
ali alexander this morning do you
remember that testimony
and you said somebody you've met on a
number of occasions stuff there i i've
seen them a couple times i don't
remember when and
it's not someone i know
let's um
pull up 67 please ps67 that's awesome
what do they have
what do they have
uh
right
let's just start i'm going to ask you to
have a look at
just the first 10 seconds of the video
it's it's just a person not even
speaking and tell me if you can identify
that person okay
[Music]
that's kelly alexander
[Music]
you know that person
that's ollie alexander
thank you let's go to um
minute 11 20.
this is this is a rather long clip and
and i'm going to take you to the middle
of it around 11 minutes and 20 seconds
next exhibit
for
please
go ahead
the anticipation
i don't know if it's video of like ollie
alexander in her bed or something
i don't know i don't know i met him once
members of congress are on a committee
um congressman steve king was the only
one who was yanked off of all committees
um but so that's not true
um
so avoid the disinformation avoid the
division
we are here to continue pressing forward
yeah congresswoman marjorie uh green
my favorite she's coming in a friend of
mine she's coming in she'll
be whatever someone's trying to tell me
you can stop it there
you see that mr alexander describes you
as
uh his favorite
right he heard him say that that's what
he said i just saw it okay do you have
any explanation for why you would feel
that way what about friends maybe
he likes the work i do what about
friends no i don't really know him that
well i've only met him a couple of times
and he describes himself as
as
is he lying when he describes himself as
a friend of yours
i don't i wouldn't call him a friend i
do not know him i've only met him a
couple of times okay so if he says he
was a friend of yours he would be lying
sometimes people say things on videos
for their followers or we know maybe i
don't know
it's that's what he said i don't know
him i've only met him a couple of times
in fact mr alexander was very active on
twitter in the post-election 2020 period
up until january 6th isn't that right
i don't know i don't follow his account
okay
um
let's go to um
look at the judge
during that post-election period from
the member when you were elected until
january 6. one of the things you were
doing was organizing people in congress
to file objections to the electoral
college council right yes working very
hard on objecting okay let's go to px3
it's not just please confused
as well as if you could scroll it
up so that we can see the bottom half
first
yeah
further down first
i'll get you a paper copy remember that
the plaintiffs council said they wanted
about an additional hour with marge
we're 37 minutes into that it doesn't
feel to me like in 23 minutes this will
be done but let we'll see
i want to focus your attention
on the box in the middle of the page
that says marjorie marjorie taylor g r e
dot dot 12 30 20. do you see that yes
and that's a twitter
comment that you made on december 30th
2020 right
i don't recall making that tweet
um but that's what this piece of paper
says you dispute it do you have any
doubt that a tweet from your account
was issued on december
30th 2020. with your account said quote
word on the hill is that mitch mcconnell
and nancy pelosi could be working
together on a rules change deal to block
our electoral college certification
objection
i don't recall this tweet
my question's a little bit different do
you have any doubt that this is a tweet
from your account i don't know
do you uh it's a yes or no question in
late december of 2020 i have doubt
rumor don't have doubt about a deal
between mitch mcconnell and nancy pelosi
to create a rules change so as to block
the objections to the electoral college
account i can't really remember it's
been 16 months or so ago that would be
pretty important wouldn't it if they
changed the rules so that you couldn't
object
to the electoral college count right
it would have been that there was no
rule change we were still able to object
or at least we tried anyways but by this
point in december of
2020
your focus was on
objecting to the electoral college count
in congress right
yes finding evidence of voter fraud and
planning to object yes
and if there had been rumors of a
rule change that would be something that
would be important for you to tweet out
and talk about publicly
if it possibly would have been i just
don't remember this tweet
i don't remember it do you dispute it um
you know that ali alexander has
responded to tweets that you've sent out
over the years right
i don't know i don't i don't know what i
have no idea who retweets and who
responds
that's not something that i spend
much time at all looking at you you
spend some time looking at it though
don't you representative
who responds to your tweets occasionally
i have some time and i look at who
responds but i do not know
what he has responded what he has
tweeted or retweeted
and and
the reason that you look at responses to
your tweets is you want to see how
what you've said is being
taken on board by other people is that
fair actually i don't really look at
comments on twitter because they're
filled with a lot of bots and a lot of
hateful people just said sometimes she
does read things like that so i really i
don't read many comments but you just
said you do some well you read mr
alexander's response to your december
30th tweet that's shown in exhibit
right and and just to read it out loud
what he writes is if they do this
everyone can guess what me and 500 000
others will do to that building
1776
is always an option you read that didn't
you
i'm if this is his twitter i see it on
the screen i have no idea those those
are his words i guess i have no idea
well as you sit here today
you understand
that what mr alexander was referring to
was not legal objections on the floor of
the congress right
no i don't know what he's referring to
and you knew back then that what mr
alexander was responding to your tweet
was to say
if they make a rules change
and congresswoman
taylor green can't object
we're going to go into the capitol and
do violence
i have no idea i don't know anything
about this
and that term 1776 is the way mr
alexander was conveying that to his
listeners or his readers
i have no idea
again i don't know anything about this
i've never seen it before
guys do let me know in the chat do you
think this goes beyond 2 30 eastern is
scheduled 21 ms green you viewed the
electoral college certification of joe
biden as a blow to freedom is that fair
i i viewed it as
we needed to object because there was so
much evidence and so many people
had signed their name thousands of
people had signed their name on
affidavits saying they witnessed voter
fraud
and that meant something to me because i
care about the people and i care about
their votes and i care about our
election integrity
my question is whether you viewed it as
a blow to freedom
if the electoral college certification
of joe biden were completed
i don't agree with your wording okay
um so no because once freedom is gone
it doesn't come back by itself right
i don't agree with your wording
the only way you can get freedom back
this is tough huh when it's earned with
the price of blood that's those are your
words right you're twisting my words and
creating a narrative that you're trying
to make though that's not my narrative
that's not that's your story
well that's not when 27 2020
that's what you said and that's what you
meant right
i'm sorry yeah on october 27 2020 when
you did the interview with mr dorr
when you said the only way to get
freedoms back is when it's earned with
blood
that's what you meant right well you
showed a video that's chopped up that
doesn't show uh my fl even my full
sentences wow so no i don't agree with
what you're saying
do you reject the idea
that you might need the violence
jimmy dore gave me digital cove
any explanation
representative greene
for why it is that
on january 5th the day before january
6th
you describe january 6th as our
1776 moment
i don't remember this is seeing this
interview is
the first time i've seen it in a long
time i don't remember now prior to
january 6 2021 you spoke publicly on
your facebook page
about the transfer of power that would
occur on january 6th you recall that
i don't recall okay
you said on a video on your facebook
page that the peaceful transfer of power
not be allowed to occur
i don't recall
you said that the peaceful transfer of
power cannot be allowed to occur because
joe biden didn't win the 2020 election
right
i don't recall
let's um go to the videotape
uh can we start with
so let me let's it's probably best if i
explain there are two versions of this
we're gonna jog your memories
and you can tell me if you think they've
been chopped up in in any way
they are they have been chopped up
that's true but you'll tell me whether
you were misinterpreted okay
the first one is px66
this is wild
so
yes can you play that one okay uh just a
second
what what's the date and the source of
the
living
the source is
it was something ms green's facebook
page is not available
this is something that was captured by
someone else and posted on another
facebook page
for
where where it says is from her facebook
page
yes i believe it does
66 because 66 has been admitted your
honor is that it said yeah it's been
admitted for what it's worth
yeah and what is the day
we're going to ask your client
okay
like it's obviously hurt
and this is an important time in our
history
we can't allow this just to just to be
gone you know just to let it go you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is that
you can't allow power to be transferred
that's you right ms green
yes that's me okay and when you say we
can't allow it we can't just let it go
the it in that phrase
is
to have joe biden declare
the winner of the 2020 presidential
election
you are showing a video where it doesn't
give us any reference beforehand and it
doesn't give us any reference afterwards
so it's not really my complete it's hard
to get an understanding of what i was
saying no it's not your answer is you
know what you're referring to
i i don't
we're watching a partial video and a
partial statement of of clearly an
interview i was doing
i don't know understand that if they
tried to play the full videos of all of
these things the judge would never in
hell allow it twitter or facebook i
can't see it from here
um
well that's you saying you can't allow
it to transfer power peacefully like joe
biden wants and allow him to become our
president because he did not win this
election that's you saying that right
that's the partial statement
of on that video okay can can we pull up
do we see the whole thing we can run the
rest of it let's see the
sure and there's another one on top of
it so we'll watch too many well you said
they're different i want to watch
everything she has an opportunity to see
what the difference can i make a
suggestion let's go back to the
beginning of this one i'm not going to
play it all the way through that'd be
good i agree let's do that
then she'll say it's only part of a
30-minute interview though
and this is an important time in our
history we can't allow this just to just
to be
gone you know just to let it go you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there the mainstream
media for four years talked about
russian collusion conspiracy theories
and lies and demanded investigations
non-stop
into russian collusion
non-stop but yet they refuse to
and this is an important time in our his
is that that where it ended
okay let's let's show uh the witness px
12.
i hope they play videos all day
let me hold off on that for one second
this video that we just saw which we
formed is
plain as 66
that's a video that you made in
anticipation
of objecting to the electoral college
count in favor of joe biden right
i don't know
it i don't see a date it's not from my
specific facebook page it appears to be
on someone else's
let's see the other video number 12.
and where is this one from
this is also um
this is way better than the johnny depp
trial for sure
off of the video on the facebook page of
the client of the congresswoman
it's off the facebook um
off of the republican accountability
project okay so this is a secondary
source yeah it was copied and but that's
where you got it from this is a
different version correct okay you want
to go ahead and play it hold on one
second and this one
is also admitted into afternoon
what it's worth for what it's worth
america re-elected donald j trump for
four more years and you can't allow it
to just transfer power peacefully like
joe biden wants and allow him to become
our president because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there there's a large
group of us we're organizing an effort
to object to the electoral college votes
for joe biden in key states where
there's real evidence that this election
has been stolen i am very convicted in
what we're going to be doing on january
6th and it's historic and i feel it's
very very important
on january 6 if you're able there are
going to be possibly a million or more
people coming to washington to be there
for this historic event it's critical
for everyone to show up and show the
nation who we are we aren't a people
that's that are going to go quietly into
the night we are not a people that are
going to be thrust into socialism
without stopping it
um
now that you've seen that clip
representative green
do you agree that this is a video that
you created in anticipation of objecting
to the electoral college vote on january
6th
this video on the democrat leftist pac
republican accountability group that
looks to be chopped up and spliced that
video that's not my full video
listen to my question yes the the words
that are shown
concentrate on the screen
those are things that you were talking
about
in anticipation of objecting to the
electoral college count vote on the
floor of congress right the only thing i
was working on was objecting but again
that's a cut and sliced video and when
you said we're organizing an effort to
object to the college
electoral college votes
on video though we
were members of congress right
well members of congress are the only
ones that can object that's that's part
of our ability
that's what we're allowed to do lawfully
right
the answer is yes exactly and making
objections
is in fact
by members of congress is part of the
lawful transfer of power right
objecting is part of the electoral uh
count process democrats did it with the
past three republican presidents that
were elected they objected and i'm sure
there was a lot of planning that went
into that and discussion uh we put a lot
of planning a lot of work into it
and as you can see we talked about it
so when you were talking about
we can't allow it to happen
you can't allow it to transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he didn't win
you weren't talking about objections on
the floor of the congress were you what
i would i believe what i was referencing
is we can't uh allow the electoral
account to happen without objecting that
i felt it was our dutiful responsibility
to object on behalf of the
large amount of voter fraud and the
people who truly felt like that there
was big problems in our elections
and
you tested you're testifying under oath
that that's what you meant when you said
you can't allow it to transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president that
was a reference to
without objecting without objecting
of course you don't say anything in that
part of the video about objections on
the floor of the congress right
would you like to see it again i believe
the video i said uh objecting but in the
sentence where you said you can't allow
it to transfer power like joe biden
wants and allowed him to become our
president because he didn't win the
election
you don't say anything in that sentence
about
objections on the floor of the congress
sir we just saw two videos that are cut
and clipped and they don't my sentences
aren't even completed
i think the first video started with me
saying and
meaning it was starting into
partially something i was already saying
what i was
from the video and my recollection from
watching him just then it was purely
talking about objecting
one of the things that you say it'd be
cool if she could give one example of
the context that would change the
meaning of what she said
um
i don't did i and i i don't remember
every single word that we just watched
let's let's look at it again i think p
p12 is the one that includes that
america re-elected donald j trump for
four more years and you can't allow it
to just transfer power peacefully like
joe biden wants and allow him to become
our president because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there there's a large
group of us we're organizing an effort
to object to the electoral college votes
for joe biden in key states where
there's real evidence that this election
has been stolen i am very convicted in
what we're going to be doing on january
it's historic and i feel it's very very
important
on january 6 if you're able there are
going to be possibly a million or more
people coming to washington to be there
for this historic event it's critical
for everyone to show up and show
so in that segment representative greene
you're asking people to come to
washington on january 6th
in this video which i saw jump three
times which means it's been cut and
spliced
yes i did talk about people coming there
to support our objection peacefully
support our objection
support president trump
um how did you know that there might be
a million or more people coming to
washington on january 6th
did you just make that up or let me tell
you that i believe those were the
numbers being talked about
the media
and just different courses
i have no idea i think i saw that on the
news
um and what you said is it's critical
for everyone to show up right that's
what we saw
supporting yeah peacefully supporting
our objection that's the only thing i
was interested in doing and planning is
objecting now the last thing you say in
the video is
we aren't the people that are going to
go quietly into the night you recall
that part yes
now that phrase we aren't the people
that are going to go quietly into the
night
that's not something that you came up
with on your own is it
i have no idea yeah i'm like jack london
borrowed from a movie script right
i don't know what you're talking about
you borrow that line from the movie
independent pendants day right
no
wow
oh please tell me they have the
videotape of that
it's bill pullman as the president in
independence day play it oh my god
oh my goodness
oh they gotta show us this
it's bill pullman as the president oh
the time stamp is
uh 108 to 144
please pull the camera
out hold on one second you've seen the
movie independence day right i've seen
it before
i i think it's probably a great movie i
haven't watched movies in a long time
but from what i remember it's a great
movie this is the one about the aliens
who come to the world and then there's a
big battle on
july 4th to ward them off right
you are giving us quite the
entertainment today thank you okay
and there's a scene in that movie where
the president the guy who's playing the
president united states addresses the
fighter pilots
against the aliens remember that scene i
do not remember no but i'm sure you're
gonna show it yeah
i've never seen anything like this can
we see the whole thing yeah can we watch
the whole baby
we're fighting for our right to live
to exist
and should we win the day
the 4th of july will no longer be known
as an american holiday
but as the day when the world declared
in one voice we will not go quietly into
the night
we will not finish without a fight
we're going to live on
we're going to survive
today
we celebrate our independence day
great great scene right
yeah that was a great scene
[Music]
the phrase that the actor uses there is
we will not go quietly into the night
you heard that
heard it just now yes and that's the
exact phrase that you use
in the video that we saw
that was
the previous exhibit
we aren't the people that are going to
go quietly
i don't view courtrooms and politics as
hollywood like you do that is not the
first person i'm sure that said that and
won't be the last and i don't
recall getting any inspiration
from this hollywood movie
like you're suggesting so you you were
not
communicating
and referencing that film
that
january 6th this is kind of some kind of
independence day
all i was talking about is objecting and
standing up for people's votes in our
elections by the way january
independence day is
july 4th right
yes
it's july 4th of 1776
that's right
this is funny but not super useful
if we're on schedule
well
i've got
a pretty short
piece left but it's up to you
i don't need a break
let's keep going great
i mean again i mean if we're talking you
know 30 minutes we're talking two hours
yeah no i don't think i swear
miss green did you advocate to president
trump to impose martial law as a way to
remain in power i don't recall
so you're not denying you did it you
just don't remember i don't remember wow
and wow
do you agree that the
storming of the capital on january 6th
is
something that you're
that's despicable
yes
very unhappy about it
now
he was really mad
we talked earlier about
a fellow named anthony aguero right
you brought up anthony aguero earlier
yes and he's somebody who you know yes
yes and somebody who you've spent a fair
amount of time with is that fair
um not much time no he's a friend of
yours someone that i do know yes and you
consider him a friend
someone i hardly ever talk to but
someone i have known for a few years
we've covered this guy before and he is
a friend of yours right a distant friend
someone i know
he refers to you as one of his closest
friends you've heard that right
and i have not okay
um
and you referred to him as amazing right
he does a lot of great work down at the
border showing the illegal invasion
constantly happening
i think that's amazing the footage that
he shows and exposes okay and you know
that mr aguero
entered the capitol
on the u.s capitol on january 6 2001
right i had heard that some time after
january 6th and you've seen a picture of
him
in the middle of the crowd you couldn't
hear before january 6 that he entered on
january 6th let's have a look at px
13
please
a little bit bigger
you gotta get her some glasses you can't
see a thing
representative green is that man in the
red circle on the left of our exhibit
13b
is that mr aguero
i don't know i can't really tell
it was reported um that was mr aguero
and that he acknowledged that publicly
would that help you discern if that's
who that is
uh
i don't really buy a whole lot of what
you say you've been using cnn and mother
jones and other terrible sources as your
sources horrible
hollywood movies so but that's what
you're trying to say now but i i don't
know if that's him or not i'm just
asking whether if i suggested to you
that he's acknowledged publicly that
that's him in the capital rotunda would
that help you identify
that your friend mr aguero
i don't see your evidence of him
acknowledging that that's him
okay
i think we can probably do something
with that
can i see 13 please
i i don't think she can see the exhibit
she's squinting like crazy i think she
just can't see well
she sometimes wears glasses right
i showed you something from cnn you
probably wouldn't accept it as authentic
would you
i think we've established that today
we'll move on
um
have you spoken to mr aguero
since january 6
i don't recall speaking to him now or
communicate with him in any way text
email no i don't recall now and
did you communicate with mr aguero at
any point prior to january 6th
about
the plans for a demonstration in
washington on january 16 no i didn't now
did he have press credentials i know i
mean there was a lot of press in there
and that's the job that he does
uh with a a border uh media company that
he he works with
so i i have no idea about what i have no
clue about it okay were you aware that
he was going to be
in his capacity i guess as a member of
the press
present on january 6th in washington for
the demonstrations that were planned no
i was not aware
communicate with any member of your
staff in any way by text or email
cell phone
about the fact that you'd be coming to
washington not to my knowledge now
did you ever discuss with mr aguero
the idea that
on january 6th
as part of the demonstration the u.s
capitol was going to be flooded by
people
no
because the only thing i was working on
objecting and had no expectation of
anything that happened on january 6.
well you knew there were going to be
demonstrations right
i knew there was a peaceful march
planned
on january 6th itself were you in
contact with anyone
who was involved in what you described
as the peaceful march that occurred that
day
no
with anybody from your staff your
congressional staff or your campaign
staff can touch by cell phone text
email
with anybody who was involved in the
day's demonstrations
not of my knowledge
at any time on january 6 did you
disclose to anyone
uh outside the capitol
your location in the capitol
during that day's events
i texted my family and told them i was
safe
anybody other than family
now
when on january 6 did you first
learn that people were entering the
united states capital unlawfully that
day
when we were in the house chamber
we were starting the electoral account
and we went on lockdown and and that's
when i first learned of it i was shocked
and do you know what time of day that
was
i don't know the exact time
and
when you went on lockdown as you
described it why don't you tell us what
that meant
what you mean by that they had to lock
all the doors in the house chamber and
they told us that
that it was on lockdown and that we
could choose to leave
or stay inside and it would be safer
inside and so i stayed inside okay
uh and when you say you stayed inside
where did you stay
inside the house chamber
and during that time that you were on
the
uh in lockdown as you put it on the
house floor um you said you were in
touch with your family to tell them you
were safe
not at that time now
when did that happen in the day
sometime later after we were evacuated
and where were you evacuated to
i i i can't disclose that location
somewhere in the capitol
and
when you were in that other location in
the capitol i presume that would be a
secure location is that right
yes great memory do you have any
communication either by phone
uh by text some other way
um with anybody who was outside the room
outside the secure location you were in
other than your family not that i recall
now
and
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it and
um
we were so confused we thought antifa
was breaking in
[Laughter]
those were the riots that had gone on
there was no evidence they were even
there
day in and day out
just horrible riots all over the country
and i thought it was the only thing that
made sense to most of us
but it was trump
uh blm rioters
is that an acronym for something
black lives matter rioters
rioters that
were attending the black lives matter
protest
remembers exactly what she was thinking
to your knowledge has anybody connected
with black lives matter movement or the
antifa movement as you say been subject
to arrest or charge in connection with
the january 6th events
i don't uh but i don't know actually i
know they were arrested all over the
country much through 2020 and over 95
percent of them had their charges
dropped unlike january 6 rioters the
answer is no they're still in jail
some of them
pre-trial
um could i have a few moments to consult
and then i think i maybe sure just yeah
we don't do we don't need a break do we
okay um
i'm five minutes if you want a five
minute break
if y'all want to step out that might be
easy for you
i think there's a room next door
so we're getting down to the end
of this series of questions to marjorie
taylor green
step now stretch your legs be free to do
something no i'm doing fine
i know how are you doing
so this has been quite an illuminating
day i i can't tell you how glad i am
that people are actually interested in
this
we've had a very steady
20-ish thousand people watching on
youtube two-ish thousand people watching
on twitch by our estimates 260 000
different people have watched some piece
of today's stream
which is uh close to entering its
seventh hour
if you can imagine welcome everybody's
welcome here if you troll the chat
you'll be banned
but everybody's welcome absolutely
i can't thank enough the
um
143 people who have either made a twitch
prime subscription or signed up on my
website i would love for you to do that
we actually are a community funded
channel and show we do a podcast every
day if you have no clue who i am i do a
show every single day
and uh out of 260 000 people
143 making a pledge is great but we
could easily double that
and you can sign up at
joinpackman.com we have a coupon code
obama
which discounts the memberships in a
comical way and you can also gift
memberships using the this is a gift box
the expectation is that there will be
about five more minutes of questions for
marjorie taylor green
okay we're keeping an eye on
from the um petitioners
thanks to romo juice and neurodivergent
woolly as well as bam for the twitch
prime subscriptions really appreciate
that uh
the website's not working the website's
working fine guys the website's working
fine
look here here's the website i'll
refresh it and as you can see perfectly
working perfectly working
i've never seen a finer website they
they my web developer came to me with
tears in her eyes
and she said sir sir sure the website's
up
tomorrow night i will be streaming the
trump rally
it should be completely insane that'll
be starting at 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m
pacific it'll be on all of our usual
platforms twitch and youtube and
facebook i hope you'll join me that's
tomorrow night
and then uh next week we've got a whole
week of uh a whole week of shows so a
lot going on
thanks to oh my goodness look at all
these great people
debonair of the wind so fevi pinchaser
owen rock
on twitch prime we love that we
absolutely love it
um any other voicemails about what's
gone on so far let's see
hey david uh do you think mike pillow is
outside the courtroom right now selling
pillows i think so his case is next
pillow's case is next we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines
other voicemails about this let's see
hey david this is ryan from north
carolina i'm a long time viewer
for your content uh in regards to the
marjorie taylor green testimony i just
want to encourage everyone out there
as tempting as it may be
do not use i don't recall as the basis
for a drinking game
please think of your health think of
your liver
do not do this yeah also if you were
drinking every time the word
quintessential was used by her defense
attorney you would probably be in the uh
in the hospital by now quite frankly
um
it's it is something else wow look at
all these people with their twitch prime
subscriptions i hope i get these
pronunciations correct
spider dog ryan chonchon pope poopin
helen killer
and others
very much appreciate that thanks to eva
whole bunch of other people matthew
chang
stephen lin
tyler faizenbaker
just fantastic people today really
fantastic people i say we go for 200
today that's how wild things are getting
here
um super chat's coming in i would think
a requirement of being a congressional
representative would be having some
recollection of what you've previously
said of course it's a legal strategy
it's a legal strategy
did anybody else notice that matt gates
looks like he's wearing a bulletproof
vest yeah
the
marjorie taylor green
uh curing if you look at it at one point
you can you can make out the shape of it
through his jacket yep
a lot of people uh
pointing that out
david there's so much evidence that
trump is the rightful winner of the 2020
election and joe biden is only the
president now because of fraud there's
so much it's like a fish david does a
fish know it's swimming in water no it
doesn't even call it that is water it's
just surrounded by the water all the
time wow okay are we back here on the
capitol we've heard questioning from
opposing council we are expecting
more testimony from representative
greene
after this break live coverage from
atlanta here on c-span okay
the one that we've seen the two
different versions all right
i'm talking about the january news max
clip
where she says this is our 1776 moment
facebook page
guys i don't think we should be hearing
this but we're going to listen to it
on the internet i mean it's very
important
you shouldn't be more trivial whether
she is
no
okay you can't you know
this is amazing
[Music]
because it shows that it's posted on the
facebook page
that's the only difference
okay we
[Music]
it seems like now
you can watch the first
15 seconds or something you don't even
have to turn it on because you'll see
it's on your facebook page that's fine
if you want to speculate to that that's
fine
but you can show that
but we don't need to watch the whole
video i don't know it's it's
just less than a minute but
but it's a very important step so
no no we
wouldn't
oh god what the hell
we keep getting we've been watching so
long that we keep getting cut off
what do we decide we're gonna do here
i'm gonna return to the subject yes ask
her if she recalls that she posted this
to her facebook page if she does
and we're done and then i'm gonna
present that okay
thanks to filthy flim for gifting five
subscriptions on twitch thanks filthy
okay
this is really something else
yeah
thank you for your patience
representative greene your honor
in the previous discussion i had asked
about
what we've marked as plains exhibit 27
which is the news max clip you recall
that we showed you remember that right
the one we've already watched
already
and i asked you whether you recall
that you posted that newsmax
clip on your facebook page
i don't recall what was posted on my
facebook page i don't make all of my
facebook posts fair enough
let's let's um
explain what this is yeah i'd like to
i'd like to show you this this is a
live version of your congressional
campaign facebook page
as it sits there today
and what we have is the clip that we had
separated
in the previous testimony and i'd like
to play that for you
just to
see if you will acknowledge that that
clip is now available on your facebook
page
that's someone else's computer
uh no it wasn't actually planned but
president trump knows how much i support
him he knows how much i support our
district
georgia's 14th district and so i was
happy to go up there and encourage our
voters to get out and vote we can't
allow our two dem our two republican
senators lose their seats to two radical
socialist democrats so i was excited to
get up there and also um cheer on
senator kelly lefler for announcing last
night that she'll be objecting to this
fraudulent stolen election tomorrow on
january 6th and i'm very excited that
both of us women
representing georgians will be fighting
for president trump and fighting for the
integrity of our elections tomorrow what
is your plan tomorrow how do you plan to
handle what could possibly go down uh in
this joint session of congress tomorrow
um are what are you prepared for
well you know i'll echo the words of uh
many of my colleagues as we were just
meeting together in our gop conference
meeting this morning this is our
1776 moment
it's green that's up on your facebook
page today right
uh if it's if that's there then yes it's
on there right and that's been posted
since january 5th 2021 correct
i don't i didn't post it but if that's
when it was posted then that's when it
was posted and things that are posted on
your facebook page are posted with your
authorization and permission right i do
not view things that are posted before
they're posted
that wasn't my question my question was
it was posted on your page that's
something that you authorized and
permitted whether you viewed it in
advance or not
um
i i think if i'm authorizing i would
view it in advance before it's posted
well no one's no no one put that up on
your facebook page without
authorization from you in some sense
right
i don't recall authorizing but you have
to
deputize someone we have staff and many
people that post interviews and so forth
on our social media for us
um
if we could make it a little bit larger
if you look in the top right
you'll see there's a message
on this green
i don't know
if we can make that larger
uh january 5th 2021
that's a comment that you posted on your
own facebook page
this is our 1776 moment
right
that is my campaign facebook page right
and that was posted up as it says on
january 5th 2021 right that's what it
says okay
um
she doesn't remember anything and other
people are in charge of all of her
websites and social media so is she
doing anything do you advocate for
martial law
with the president of the united states
i don't recall i don't recall
um you know president trump right yes
yeah he's um
supported you politically right
yes and
obviously a very important person
in general right yes 45th president of
the united states i consider that very
important right
yes and you had meetings with him
between
the election 2020 and
january 20th
of 2021 right
yes
he remembers that meetings you discuss
with him
your advocacy for the idea that there
should be martial law declared in the
united states no i don't recall ever
discussing that are you saying it didn't
happen or you're saying you don't call
one of the other i don't recall ever
discussing that
did you discuss that topic
the idea that there should be martial
law
declared in the united states
prior to the inauguration of president
biden your honor i'm going to have to
which i actually represent president of
the united states and that's covered by
executive privilege she can't get into
this conversation exactly
she's not a member of the executive and
this council is here on her behalf not
on mr trump's behalf unless there's
something i miss okay it's not a proper
objection
i'm sorry i've got questions what was
the question again the question was
whether
prior to the inauguration of joe biden
ms green whether you ever uh advocated
for martial law to be imposed in a
conversation with the chief staff of
then president united states mr trump
you can answer the question i don't
recall
um did you ever advocate for martial law
prior to the inauguration of mr biden
any member of the white house staff that
was part of the trump administration i
don't recall
are you aware of any other
congressional elected congressional
representatives advocating for martial
law
to stop the peaceful transfer of power
before the inauguration was divided
i don't remember i'm hearing yes is the
real answer um
do you regard the people who were
arrested
and charged in connection with the
january 6th events as patriots
i
i don't
i don't think them being arrested and
charged on january 6th affects the fact
that they're
patriots or not oh
yeah some of them are veterans yes some
of them definitely are patriots wow
and we have um px60
wow
please proceed governor sir
which one is this
px
[Music]
some of them are better
he just remembered something guys this
is a crucial moment
he's getting pissed
in front of you while we've marked his
uh petitioners exhibit 60 which is a
story that appeared in the washington
post
on january 5th 2021
did you read that story in the
washington post
i don't think i've read this one
um you recall hearing that the
washington prior to january 6 did you
recall hearing that the washington post
was reporting that
there there were concerns that there
were going to be violence and there was
going to be violence in washington on
january 6th
i i had not heard that i heard no
threats of violent side that i remember
at all for january 6.
can we also look at
px4
i'm going to show you this
[Applause]
the screen i placed before you a january
5th 2021 article
entitled violent threats ripple through
far-right internet forms ahead of
protest
this is a an article that appeared in
nbc news on the 5th
you recall
reading
the nbc was reporting that there were
violent threats
that were expected to occur on january
6th that they reported that on the 5th
of january
sir we were really busy just preparing
to object on the 6th i don't recall that
news report
have you read this news report before
not until you placed it in my hand okay
probably didn't have much time to read
it no um let me consult for one minute
i say go all day just keep going
oh yeah
one last thing um
um
he told us earlier in the day that you
were suspended from your twitter account
or permanently taken off twitter is that
right permanently banned
um you're not banned from facebook
though right
yeah and we saw your live facebook page
just a couple of minutes ago right you
pulled that up yes you did
and
on your facebook page you have
directed that certain videos be removed
from the facebook page right
i
don't recall one of the videos that you
have removed was the one from february
of 2019
where it talked about a sea of people
and
flooding the capital
and violence in the capital in
connection with fund the wall matter
right
i don't know what you're referring to
you had your staff take that one down
didn't you i don't refer i don't know
what you're referring to facebook never
ordered you to take any video off your
facebook page did they
i don't recall
i have nothing further on
well what an honest and forthcoming
testimony you need a break
oh no i'm doing great okay
again i don't think will not take long
and i assume you can have a break to get
ready for a final hour yeah
that'd be perfect thank you
representative graham i'm going to take
you back to january 6.
you've already testified that
that you are on lockdown in the
house chamber
you've already testified that you were
on lockdown in the house chambers
yes
and um
did you have an opportunity to do a
video
yes
and tweet accompanying that video yes
and about what time did that occur on
january 6th
i believe it was around 2 30
in the afternoon
and where were you when the video was
when you took the video
i was inside the house chamber and we
had gone on lockdown and i it was after
i had learned that
there had been some violence uh outside
the capitol and someone had been shot
and there uh was
just people that we were only told there
were people inside the capitol
and i got very concerned because at that
time i was confused i was so confused i
was shocked
i'd never been in anything violent
before any kind of situation like that
and i was really scared
and i went inside this okay chat will
she cry
we're in the republican cloakroom
into one of the phone booths where
you can go to make a phone call or
anything i went inside there and i made
a video uh
telling people uh to be peaceful not to
be violent uh and just giving out a
message
and i tweeted that what an incredible
memory for every detail minute by minute
it's really amazing at that time who was
attacking the capitol
no i didn't know there were there was
people were saying different things we
mostly thought that it was antifa
dressed up as trump supporters that was
the first thing we were told
uh we we had no idea i was in the club
room couldn't see the news
i just knew that we were on lockdown and
and they said by that point they said
you cannot leave you have to stay in
here
our working theory was it was antifa
with trump gear trump flags saying trump
things having been at the trump rally
this this has already been admitted yeah
right
yeah and who told her that
is this your tweet is this your face
yes
did you say in this tweet
a message from me comfortable
what
be safe
be smart
be peaceful
obey the laws
this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump and support election integrity
god bless
yes by the grace of god her memories
back
r-1
somebody got that set up i don't see
devon he was setting up oh
mr henson said he would play a church uh
dominic
wait a second sorry no i don't see him
in the courtroom yeah devon was set it
up yesterday okay
i'm sorry in the morning
of course we're about to get hit with a
hype train on twitch by the way i think
that's the universal rule of life
people just tuning in have missed a lot
i can't you're gonna have to scrub back
yesterday
i know
again i apologize
i mean i have
this may be it
i have
that's it
is that it
i mean
i guess it's been in my custody
the computer
her lawyer is horrifying yeah it's crazy
they've had lunch already guys
we don't know what they have by the way
how are the calzones pizza is
in here we have subway tomorrow
uh we've got a tech team coming in
i
well
we'll take five minutes i mean you know
people are not going to leave and come
back in five minutes it's going to take
a minute to set it up sorry for it
it's all right
i guess
is this guy right here praying or is he
on his phone
okay so it needs to stare at you
disconnected
if anyone in the room is watching my
stream please lift your hand now
and turn to the camera in the back
please
so
well it's quite a situation um
let's see if i can sneak in one
voicemail
hi um my name is ashley i am a big fan i
watch you on
youtube uh and i just want to say about
the marjorie taylor green
hearing that's going on right now i keep
waiting and wanting
the guy questioning her to be like
is this your tweet is this your video
madam congress person
and i know that that doesn't actually
happen that only happens on tv but like
weirdly i feel like that is something
that
is like this is the real life equivalent
of that sort of thing that would be on
tv i think that is what's been happening
there's matt gates uh no it's i know a
lot of people seem to think he's wearing
a bra i i think the speculation is that
it's a bulletproof vest or kevlar of
some kind
it's not clear
um hi my name is elizabeth bornemann i i
watch you all the time i'm watching the
representative roger taylor green trial
and i was wondering if they were aware
of the willard hotel video i think that
is the smoking gun
she can't blame it on cnn on anything
it's literally her coming out and i'm
not sure the cast of characters
um you know there are oaths all right
well let's look into that i don't know
you know
somebody called in about my lunch
hi david that sandwich was total
[ __ ] turkey cheddar
mayo i mean come on why don't you just
eat a bucket of ice cream or something
like that that's not the way vegetables
work you can't just eat junk food and
then have a handful of vegetables will
be good you have to fill your stomach
with vegetables primarily because
they're the most calorie dense sparse
foods and then you top it off you have a
little bit wow this is a very sick
collar
very very sick
hey dave this is charles lane again
actually let's listen to the hot mic
so technical trouble continuing to
plague this
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
goodbye
let me recover my ears for one second
yeah
this is jonathan in los angeles if
marjory taylor green has kicked off the
ballot because of the 14th amendment
wouldn't that be a precedent to prevent
trump from running again
maybe so
no there's i don't see this as having a
high chance of success and there is a
lot riding on it
without a doubt
thank you to michael widdell and also
thank you to mike swink
for the twitch for the
joinpacman.com membership
congresswoman is this your face
yes
it's been spliced though
i want to say thank you to annelise s
who just gifted a membership on my
website annelise sends the membership
and this free membership goes to
uh let's see the 26th one today
and it is
to brian gray
if you want a free membership go to
davidpakman.com
free membership there are currently 650
no
668 people
668 people waiting for free memberships
you can gift them
on my website
bobby is it ready yeah okay turn it on
let's go ahead let's go i think we're
just trying to fix them all you have to
turn the volume up i hear
several times
president trump uh that are here in
washington dc today
today uh is the time to support your
president and just knows
wonderful american who support president
trump
that are here in washington dc today
today
is the time to support your president
and just know that we're fighting for
you here in the capitol in congress
fighting for your vote and fighting for
president trump so i urge you to remain
calm i i urge you to have a peaceful
protest um
make sure that everyone is safe and
protected and and let's do this in a
peaceful manner this is this is not a
time for violence this is a time to
support president trump support our
election integrity and support this
important process that we're going
through in congress um where we're
allowed to object uh so this is this is
very important so i urge you to stay
calm um be the great american people
that that i know you are and just know
that we're we're in here fighting for
you so god bless everyone be careful be
safe and and be smart and and obey the
laws thank you very much
representing the green is that you
yes
as i look at your face
hear your voice
i think you're scared objection
this is this is not for mr bob to
testify about his feelings
what was your feelings at the time
i i was scared
i was very scared i was concerned
i was shocked
shocked absolutely shocked uh every time
i said we're going to fight
it was all about objecting and to me
that was the most important process of
the day
and i i
had no idea what was going on and i just
didn't want anyone to get hurt i didn't
want to
see anything terrible happen
and it was it was very upsetting i was
very very upset when i made that video
and you've been on the stand for several
hours here during direct examination
and they showed you multiple tweets
and multiple videos
did they show you that video
no they didn't they didn't show that one
or
all the other social media posts that is
have been made on my account that i have
made
um or videos i have made where i've
always denounced violence and all the
videos i've said and speeches i've said
of how upset i was
about the right i literally supported
violence in some of the videos shown
today
against it
and even when i went and visited the
january 6th defendants pre-trial
defendants in the d.c jail
and i went there
to see their conditions because we had
heard horrible things about their
treatment i don't know what this is
relevant to i object
the fact that it's not relevant but it's
absurd
that's the word cutting you off is going
beyond the question thank you
now let me show you what's been admitted
as our before
[Applause]
so this is a transcript of the video
that's been emitted into evidence
and i want you to turn to page two
and use did you say these words
so i urge you to remain calm i urge you
to have a peaceful protest
make sure everyone is safe and protected
and let's do this in a peaceful manner
this is this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump support our election integrity and
support our important process that we're
going through in congress
where we're allowed to object
so this says this is very important so i
urge you to stay calm
be the great american people that i know
you are and just know that we're we're
in here fighting for you
so god bless be careful be safe he
remembers and obey the law thank you
yes
i think there's a subsequent tweet
that you did
referring to the violence that occurred
on
january 6
and it's p
one p
and i am actually not certain whether
that has been admitted or not embedded
p1
c1p
i didn't
so representative grain did you
tweet
this tweet
i know what i'm talking about
um
i don't remember but i see it's my
mt green
twitter account
so it it went up from your twitter
account but you don't know if you did it
or another member of your staff or
another person
i can't recall exactly but i think i
tweeted this one this one she thinks was
her
yep this one she remembers what a
miracle huh this says what a miracle
today is january 12th is that correct
yes
this tweet says i proudly stand with
representative
and everything in his statement which
you link to later on
the unhinged left is out of control and
the disgusting witch hunt is full of
hypocrisy
democrats are on record for support of
violence all year
we did not plan
cause
and denials
and that's capital letters
denounce the january 6th attack
i defend my honor
and reputation
so was that the message sent out on your
twitter account
yes it's the same message i've said over
and over again about january 6.
now
representative excuse me
fbi director christopher wray
testified before congress
that soon after the attack it was before
the senate on march 2nd 2021
and this is r5
which has been admitted into evidence
and let me show you this
are you moving to the admissions
i don't it has i don't believe this has
been admitted all right are you moving
to the news yes i am
any objection
i move no objection
thank you thank you
now when he testified before congress
on march 2nd of course you're a member
of congress right
yes
and he said
i was appalled
like you at the violence and destruction
that we saw that day he's referring to
january 6
yes
i
i was appalled that you
is testifying before congress looking at
members of kaiser
our country's elected leaders
were victimized
right there
in these very halls
were you affected by the attack
yes
i was i was in the house chamber when it
happened
i had to be evacuated to safety we were
held for hours in a
secret location
protected by capitol police military
members
for hours until they cleared the capitol
yes i was a victim of the riot that day
no further questions
your honor um i believe the testimony
has opened the door on
uh the issue of
um text messages that representative
greene sent
on january there you go during the
insurrection
we would call for their media production
and the ability to have a moment to look
at them so we can examine her on them i
thought she i thought the testimony was
she did not send any other message no
she's testified that she sent messages
to her children and her family
those were text messages
those were not tweets we did not talk
about any text messages
that was the controversy over the
admission of the text messages which we
have not referred to right at all except
that representative green referred to it
when i asked her if she was in touch
with anybody
uh from the from uh that day from the
floor and she said she texted her family
you can't open the door hold on
do you have any questions other than
that i do and i'm going to preserve that
position but i understand we're going to
take a break um it's been a little
chaotic for the last few minutes
you mentioned a number of uh
statements that you made after january 6
where you talked about being upset about
the fact that there was violence right
yes can you point to one
press release
or tweet
or comment on facebook prior to january
6th where you use the word
peacefully
and
in terms of urging people to behave
peacefully
at the demonstrations that were expected
to occur
i would have to look all through my
social media but i'm sure that it's
there i've and i've always denounced
violence i've denounced those
antifa blm riots all over the country
over and over just like i denounced the
january 6 riot over and over even even
to the people in jail i told them that
it was wrong i told them in the dc jail
i did not like what they did
but that i'm there because i support
their due process rights which is being
violated
um can you point to one video prior to
january 6 where you urge people to
behave peacefully on january 6th no one
time in public it's on video where you
said those words
i don't have a computer i don't have my
social media
i didn't i didn't remember
many of the
social media posts that you pulled up in
interviews
i was interested that you um
answered some questions about fbi
director ray's testimony in congress um
do you believe the fbi
uh was behind the january sixth violence
at the capitol
i don't know i certainly think there's a
lot to be investigated we don't know who
ray epps is the scaffolding commander oh
god we don't the governor whitmer's plot
certainly oh my god two questions about
things that happen on january 6 i think
there's a lot of investigations that
need to happen you you've referred to
january 6 as a fed's erection right
i'm i'm not sure okay
okay
anything else just about before we take
our break no anything else
okay do they rest or do you rest no we
have
well we have an issue that we want to
insult on but
either we're going to put in a video or
we're going to move to closing
statements but the video has been
admitted so it's a timing issue that we
want to talk about all right
so you don't need the witness she's
excused
that's right thank you
thank you thank you representative you
are excused i step down and that's the
conclusion of the marjorie taylor green
portion of the testimony
what do you want to do mr kelly i mean
you want to take a break i don't know
what i don't know what you're
contemplating after five minutes or now
yeah i think
your honor we would appreciate a very
short break well let's take 15 and be
back let's be back at uh quarter two
you're on our last question
are we absolutely
dedicated to stopping at 4 30 if we went
a little longer than that i will have to
consult with okay the real powers
only because we want we're trying to
figure out our presentation the last
piece of our presentation if we want to
close or do we have stuff one more thing
and so it would be nice to know we will
i will consult with
judge mali and we will respond and we
can reconvene thank you
okay we're off to the 15 minutes judge
malihi can i chat with you about
logistical questions
all right so that concludes marjorie
taylor green's testimony what is
following will be
um closings that there may be one video
already in evidence that will be played
but it will be closing statements from
what side from both sides
then that will be the end of the
proceedings and then the judge is going
to take time and at some point render a
recommendation to the georgia secretary
of state brad raffensberger as people
have pointed out
brad raffensberger is up for re-election
and it seems extraordinarily unlikely
even if the judge were to recommend
pulling her off the ballot that
raffensberger is going to do it because
i think it would have significant
repercussions for raffensberger so we
are not going to get that resolution
today and i have a hard out so our
coverage will end now at uh close to the
start of the eighth hour of coverage for
today i really appreciate everybody who
joined me if you want to keep subjecting
yourself to this you absolutely are free
to there are endless streams and
coverage of it
but i will be back with you tomorrow
night there will be a donald trump rally
it will probably be extremely corrosive
to democracy
and trump uh uh well let's just leave it
at that let's not say anything else it
will likely be extremely corrosive to
democracy make sure you're following me
on twitch make sure you have subscribed
on youtube what a day
we'll see everybody tomorrow